Start Broadcast and then update to
update to twitter and then I always
liked to watch my own channel,
so let's go to your own channel so you
can see that the chat is your shows when
I press pause on that unit.
On this.
No,
no.
On the right.
And then a date year.
Internet tonight.
Update my married go faster.
One.
You're going to get addicted to those
nice colors pretty before 21 minutes
ago.
Oh,
that's twitter.
See now people are going to ask
questions.
It's just twitter.
All right,
let me go to my website.
What does my ustream?
Yeah,
just click or go back to that other
page.
You know,
but that's not.
I think this one is it one?
Is it?
Yeah,
you don't,
you don't want to have too many windows
open because we're going to be killing
your internet is killing it right now.
So I would except that one.
And now and maybe even close your tweet
deck.
Really?
Well,
not tweet deck.
I guess it.
Let me give states everyone's going on.
Um,
she already say you're already getting
it.
I think that's huge.
Yeah,
totally.
Oh yeah.
Screen Vernon.
Huh?
You got screen Bernan Hill you're
talking about.
Go back to your message board for say
that Tyler on the way.
Right?
See that?
Yeah.
What is that?
Looks like.
Screen burning.
Right?
But it's only the image that's.
But I think there's a transparency
issue.
Okay.
What is the channel though?
This isn't the channel.
Is rates
try upstream upstream.
That TV backslash channel.
Joe Rogan life was like.
Yeah,
right there.
Try.
You can try it out.
Yeah.
Just killed it.
Damn.
This is slow as fuck,
right?
Yeah.
And then when we get fancy we can put
your website address and we put graphics
and all that stuff.
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo
Doo Doo Doo.
This is slow as fuck.
Pause that one screen.
You know where we're watching yourself
live?
Yeah.
Okay.
Hi.
So this is how you guys doing?
Hi,
we're doing great.
Which one is your water?
Hi everybody.
Yeah,
if you want to watch the chat,
you click on this and people could chat
live.
You know?
That's good.
We are broadcasting live.
This is my office says Brian,
call Ak.
Red Band.
Hello world.
Fuck is going on.
Uh,
the questions are coming in now.
How are you guys doing?
We,
we're doing swell.
I can't think of quite high enough for
this.
I forgot we even started off camera.
Marijuana use bullet into the camera.
The fuck is that for fire in this room
as.
How is the quality of sound and video
wise?
Yeah.
How's the quality sound video wise?
Does it sound right?
Can you see us?
All right?
When someone says they're already hard,
that's amazing.
We've got somebody's heart.
Dude.
This is not this.
See this right here.
This guy is above that.
But those guys.
And on this.
What's that all about?
See?
Yeah.
So we'd
dead air bad brogan.
Whereas going.
Yeah,
we just started this.
It's not very good.
I apologize.
It's that person probably.
No,
it's not.
See this guy right here?
More red.
See good sound quality.
Yeah.
The video.
Oh,
let's see.
Different Guy,
his twitter,
his twitter tweets not coming through.
Oh,
that might be a.
and maybe something weird fight.
I was talking about that where they sit,
the sound and video.
Snowflakes falling or a bit annoying.
Oh,
come on.
It's Christmas.
Wouldn't make video and sound are okay.
But the snowflakes are annoying.
Does everybody feel like they're
snowflakes are annoying?
Is just one dude that's kind of anal
about what he looks at the screen.
Come on man.
It's beautiful snowflakes.
Merry Christmas.
You Fox.
Are you doing everybody?
Merry Christmas,
my friend.
You got to change it.
Now we'll just add something else called
bubbles to have bubbles.
Bubbles.
Bubbles will add levels.
And here it's just for 98 o two.
Cool.
And then we'll add a clock
for that guy.
This is for 2000.
No,
we don't need to kill the clock.
Clocks.
Ridiculous.
Anyways,
you can go through it and then if you
want to,
an exit will take him off.
Oh,
this is good.
Comic Book.
What's coming next comic.
Oh,
that's okay.
Yeah.
So then you can see.
Scroll down.
Bubbles and snowflakes.
Let's see what flame on does that far.
That's good.
That either.
Hmm.
Glow.
Shall we go?
No,
Michelle.
Not.
And you could change like sometimes they
have options,
so if you wanted to glow less drag.
Oh let's go to the Matrix.
Black helicopters started acre.
Maybe it's just the matrix.
So where did I go see if you know.
This
is terrible.
Terrible idea.
NASA.
That's an asset.
Just don't pixelate pop art always
looked gross.
Thermal thought bubble here again.
And then you could type in what you want
right there.
Oh,
I love it.
Okay,
that's good.
How much does this shit is annoying?
Probably the bubbles.
The bubbles are annoying and me just
sitting in front of the fucking
computer.
Just go on.
How about this?
How does an orange.
Because people watching this,
like why don't you show them this
awesome box if somebody needed it?
Yeah.
This is an awesome boss.
That some wonderful couple hearings to
me.
I'm not sure of the dude made it or the
girl made it.
But this is like a,
a killer stash box that this is to cool
people gave me.
Well actually the guy made it
[inaudible] the girl made the pipe.
Now remember the girls,
uh,
a glass blower.
But is this wild box would like this
cool Alex Grey Art on it,
you know,
it's like really trippy stash box and
some guy made it to me and gave it to me
after one of his shows.
I wish I knew the dude's name because
it's very cool.
And the box has like little place where
you would keep your tobacco.
She made this killer a little pipe and
he may get it away from the snowflakes,
but uh,
whoever they are,
if they're watching this,
highly unlikely.
But if nobody's watching this,
don't do what?
We have 10 people in here now.
Is this Channel One hundred 13 already?
Wow.
Okay.
This is like a 13 people's,
like a show at a comedy club.
Now I feel pressure.
He's got a weird hundred 30 peoples.
Like we have to be a,
we have to be entertaining.
So let's read the twitter feed and see
what the fuck is up.
Bitches.
Let's see.
To stash,
how dare you.
It's not a stash.
This is Madison.
It's called train wreck.
And you see her right there.
And you see right there,
this,
if you don't know if you're from out of
town,
that Red Cross and the marijuana leaf,
this is medical marijuana,
so this is totally legal in the state of
California.
It's pretty trippy because you drive
down the street and I was driving those
street yesterday and we were looking for
places where we could,
uh,
you know,
we could see how many places are near my
house.
There's like fucking 20 places within a
couple miles of my house that I can go.
And a lot of them they just say collike
collective on it.
It'll say like,
you know,
West hills collective or you know,
fucking Dick Street collective,
whatever.
And it'll have a red cross.
And that's all you need to know.
And everybody knows that it's weed.
They have letters,
everybody uses green letters and they're
everywhere.
And you go.
And if you have one of these right here,
this is Brian,
you see this,
this is a real legitimate recommendation
from a doctor and this,
all you do is you go to a doctor,
you say,
marijuana helps me sleep,
whatever.
And the doctor will give you one of
these legitimate recommendations up
upper a legal prescription state of
California for marijuana.
And then you go to these places and some
of them you can pay with a credit card.
So trippiest thing ever.
You buy weed with a credit card and
you're like,
what year is this?
Two thousand and nine.
But the rest of the country still living
in the dark ages.
Colorado is catching up.
Colorado has a bunch of places now
Colorado actually is going to open up a,
um,
a medical marijuana restaurant and
they're gonna open up some 30,000
square foot weeds superstore and
boulders fucking gigantic.
It's like three stories.
Isn't Texas even doing like a vote soon
or a lot of people are trying in a lot
of states are trying to chat.
A Massachusetts recently made it,
uh,
they decriminalized it.
It was a,
they don't have any medical law yet
there,
but now it's completely not legal,
but it's not illegal.
It's a weird thing.
Like you're not allowed to sell it.
Like possession is one thing,
but selling it as a different thing,
you're still not allowed to sell it,
which is fine.
Like people fucking grow it,
you know?
Really fucking hunter.
S Thompson had it,
right?
Hunter s Thompson.
When he was running for sheriff,
he was saying that no drug good enough
to be taken,
should be allowed to be sold.
That was like a law that he's going to
pass in Aspen and he was to call aspen
fat city.
It's going to change the name of Aspen
to fat city who's going to tear up all
the roads and saw the streets.
So it was all dirt roads everywhere and
fucking lost by 400 votes.
It's only 400 votes.
He can't.
He,
if he won,
if he was the,
the,
the sheriff of Aspen,
that would've been fucking bad ass.
But one of the things that he wanted to
have was that any drug that you can take
that was good enough to be taken,
should it be legal?
And he's fucking totally right.
You know,
if people want weed,
it should be.
People should trade things where we,
oh,
you know what,
fuck it,
you should be able to buy it if you want
to,
but the problem with that is,
you know,
then you're going to get some really
unscrupulous people that just want to
sell pot,
you know,
they just want sell it and they didn't
want to make profit off of it.
And then it becomes like anything else,
the,
they try to cut out the competition.
Like,
like one of the weed stores that I go
to,
there's a guy right next door to them,
the that opened up like I'm talking like
right next door.
Like there's maybe like one storefront
between two weeds doors and the guy's
pissed off and he's,
fuck,
this guy's a dick.
That's totally not in the spirit of you
know what marijuana is supposed to be.
I mean,
you're not supposed to be opening up
right next store to a dude until his
competition,
but he shouldn't be like,
fuck that dude.
That dude,
dude,
he's just another dude selling weed.
Yeah.
I shouldn't be doing it right next to
you.
Yes,
correct.
But don't be an asshole.
You're fucking selling wheat.
Hell no,
you ain't fixing the hunter.
S Thompson is my hero and I'm planning
full sleeves of Ralph steadman.
Art.
Are you really?
Wow.
That's a fucking good idea.
Stedman,
Stedman or Steedman.
I forget.
I say his name is Steven fucking.
I love his art.
His art.
It's perfectly.
Goes like a.
what's the word I'm looking for?
Compliments.
Hunter s Thompson's writing.
You know,
that guy just fucking nailed it from the
very first time they work together.
When they did that.
Um,
the Kentucky Derby is decadent and
depraved from that story all the way on
to fear and loathing in Las Vegas stuff.
Ralph Guy,
he fucking nailed it.
He,
he was here.
He's hanging with hunter.
He totally got the vibe that,
that hunter was writing.
He totally got where hunter was.
Seeing things,
you know,
I've just started getting into hunter s
Thompson really recently.
I was a,
I guess maybe a year and a half ago.
I was staying in a hotel room in Seattle
and I ordered up a Gonzo on the,
uh,
the paper view and the hotel just
because nothing else look good.
Said,
fuck it,
I'll just check this out and I'm
immediately became a hunter.
S Thompson fan started reading his books
and I'm reading the One,
I'm reading what I'm reading now.
It's this one great shark.
It's great.
It's got everything in there.
So a bunch of different shifts here and
load things in there.
The Kentucky Derby's a lot.
A lot of great stores like a collection
of his works,
the quintessential well need to open
grow homes with retail fronts.
Yeah man,
keep it easy.
That's what I'm talking about.
If you've never been to a grow room
before,
I've only been to one grow room.
It was pretty interesting.
There was a um,
a place in la where they,
uh,
they,
it was a full service place.
You can get a prescription there,
you could get weed there and you could a
picture with me.
The Kid,
uh,
get weed there and they grew it.
So there was like this back room where
they had all these lights set up and it
was pretty fucking tripping man.
Like it was a,
a big ass room and it was filled with
these plants and they were all lit up
and you walked through the plants and if
like,
yeah they were alive,
you know,
they're living plants,
but it felt like,
like they were conscious.
Maybe it was because I was really high.
That might be,
but maybe because I was really high I
was able to tune into it.
But it was,
it was a very weird sensation.
It felt like I was around like living
entities.
Like it didn't just feel like they were
plants.
It felt like they were alive,
you know?
It was very strange.
It was cool.
I thought about,
I was like,
that'd be cool to have something like
that in my house,
but that's pretty illegal federally.
At least,
you know,
if they caught you with a bunch of
plants in your house,
you know,
and they'd be like,
hey bitch,
what are you doing with those?
You're allowed to have.
Yeah.
Are we allowed to have a bunch?
You can have up to six plants.
I did actually,
because you have that x.
Oh that's right.
I haven't exemption because I'm a
fucking real stoner is to have these
fucking with us here.
No,
but you can.
You can totally turn off that second
one.
Just one.
Yeah.
Sorry folks.
Getting organized.
This is the first time I've.
I,
I'm always threatening to do some shit
like this and I never followed through.
Why were the UFC ring?
Girls fired?
I do not know.
They were very nice.
All of them were two girls were fired.
They left Mariani.
Who?
A very nice person as well.
I've been friends with her for years.
She's super cool.
Chick and I very hot.
Probably classically beautiful,
like it doesn't get anymore.
Beautiful face.
Very nice person too.
You can follow her on twitter.
She's on twitter.
She wants.
It's the one with the fake wigs.
Still working.
What are you talking about?
Fake Wig.
Dare you.
First of all,
how dare you?
How dare you fuck with her whole career.
One with the fake wig.
She has a.
are you talking about
the one with the big hair then?
Seventies hair.
She looks like she has seventies.
Harold Hamm.
She just started like maybe.
Oh the.
Yeah.
Her name was logan.
She did not have fake here.
That was her hair was real.
Yeah.
Should we just have some curly hair and
that social workers.
Very recognized girl.
The Atlanta housewives thing you need to
have that wakes are back,
so I thought that was all of those.
You might be right.
It might be right.
Unless you're watching housewives of
Atlanta show.
There's nothing like.
First of all,
there's nothing like white girls around
black girls when they start talking
black.
I read that Shit.
I love when white guys do it.
I love them.
White girls do it.
To me,
it's just like watching chimps.
If the zoo,
when they fuck each other and they go
crazy,
it's like,
wow,
look at.
This is weird.
This is interesting.
But white people around black people,
they start acting black.
There's no better example than the
Steven Seagal show.
Holy Shit.
Have you seen what he does that he pulls
up to a group of black people.
It's like,
what up Cuz what's going up?
Oh Dude.
Much love,
much love.
He talks black,
like really condescendingly and then you
know when he's in the car.
When the cameras aren't,
he'll talk like Buddhist,
he says,
he says stupid shit,
you know,
the one monk was walking with the
younger monk and the younger monk says,
what is the way of Buddha that way?
And so the older monk throws him in the
water deep.
He talks like he's two totally different
dudes.
He talks like the Steven Seagal,
who's like the mystical man and the
Steven Seagal who is this fucking
strange cop in Louisiana.
He has a southern accent that he uses
part of the time,
part of the time and then occasionally
he drops a southern accent and he goes
with a full on black accent like waves
in the hood,
but Steven Seagal is a fucking cop,
like for real.
Like he puts on a bulletproof vest.
He gets in his fucking car and they go
fight crime and it's like,
who is letting him do this?
Like how crazy is that?
All you have to have is a cup of fucking
movies.
You've seen his website.
Oh,
genius.
Yeah,
it's awesome.
Is it Steven Seagal Dot com?
I think so.
I've seen Jim.
Can you seen Jim Carey's website?
Has the most amazing website and the
whole entire room.
It's a pretty cool.
I've never seen better website.
Yeah,
it's very,
very unique,
but when I see websites like that,
I wish I still tripped on shrooms all
the time because I would just sit at his
website.
Yeah,
no shit.
Oh,
beyond the mind.
Xy is fucking.
What the fuck.
He's going to attack this behind me.
The sign is a point of controversy from
dementia.
When I hosted the.
I know.
It's terrible.
Listen,
we thought it was terrible too.
We got.
We got fucked when we.
When Doug Stam hope,
but I want to do that show.
They lie to us.
They told us you can do nudity.
We'll blur it out.
You can swear.
We'll beep it out.
We want you to go crazy.
We want to get sued.
It's going to be great publicity.
And then when we started doing it,
first of all,
Janet Jackson,
polar nipple out and everybody went
fucking crazy.
Crazy feeling the effects from that.
So amazing.
Like literally,
television got set back a decade because
of Janet Jackson's nipple and the big
thing was that they were showing it
during the dinner hour and children are
watching.
Well isn't a woman's nipple,
are we that fucking crazy.
It's not like she had a rifle up her
pussy.
It's a fucking nipple,
you know?
That's where babies feet.
It's.
Is it that offensive babies?
It is,
man.
That's the first one.
We're talking about it during the,
during the dinner hour.
Somebody had a really good point when
this happened.
Like he said,
isn't that like the first meal?
That's like the dinner breasts.
Yeah.
You see that when you.
Since you were a kid.
Well,
you know,
especially having kids on my own now
when I see Mrs Rogan make fucking milk
with their tents and the tents are dead
to me.
I don't suck on them anymore.
But what's more important is that you
look at them and you say,
that's like those are.
That's like where food comes from.
Like it's not offensive.
But anyway,
this thing behind us make me hard.
This is how fucking stupid they were
when we were doing the show.
There was an argument and we hit,
we came up with a game show called you
make me hard and what it was is the guy
would be strapped into a chair and he to
have this box on his dick and with a
light would go off on the box and you
know,
the light would indicate that he has a
boner and so we'd have like midgets
eating bananas and Shit.
No.
Oh,
he's getting hard.
You know,
we,
it was Kinda Corny,
but what we really.
The reason why we did it is one of the
gags was we had this really hot chick
and she climbs all over him.
The audience is going fucking crazy.
They're going nuts.
And this really hot chick at the end of
this,
he pulls her tits out.
He's sucking on a tense whipped cream,
the whole deal.
And then she pulls her panties off and
she's got a dick and the audience goes
crazy.
She was a tranny and I mean I've never
heard a bigger wave of disappointment
that when this,
this tranny pulls out this Dick and she
was taking all kinds of hormones,
so it was like addicted,
had been poisoned.
It looked like dead.
It was like dark.
It was dark and shriveled up like it
burned,
like chemically burned.
Like it was like a little little dead
monkey dick and smell it.
And she pulled it out and she starts
like swinging it around in the fucking
audience went crazy and the guy sitting
in the chair just had this look on his
face of horror.
Well,
they approved all that,
but what they wouldn't approve is that
the name of the show make me hard.
They said that we had a name is show,
make me stiff.
I guess like an argument like for real,
like there's a difference.
Like they,
they mean the same thing just to make me
stiff doesn't sound,
it doesn't sound quite as funny.
Really doesn't matter.
I mean what's the difference?
But the point was that they were willing
to argue this.
That was a big deal for them.
And that shows you how these shows work,
the best shows like,
like standup Comedians,
like if you take a guy like Dave
Chappelle or you know Kat Williams or
anybody,
any good comic that you like,
they write all their own shit.
They write it,
they perform it,
they're saying shit that they think is
funny.
They're the producer,
they are the performer there.
The whole ball of wax or the writer
there,
everything.
And that's why you get a pure product
because you get a product that's from
this dudes mind.
Well what happens is when you like start
working on a television show,
these people that are working for the
network,
somebody has to work for the network and
you would assume that the people at the
very top of the food chain are the
perfect people for the job.
But that's not true.
They're just people that somehow or
another got that fucking job and a lot
of them,
they like to think that they know what's
good.
They like to think they have an iphone
and they always want to put their
footprint on it.
They want to put their hand print on it.
They want to change something and
anything that we,
I think the background should be blue.
We're going to ruin the whole show with
this red background and they'll go crazy
and they'll fucking fight over this.
Why?
Because they want to be the ones say,
well,
it wasn't me that decided for the blue
background.
If they didn't go with that blue
background,
the was shit and my right,
and then the wife will agree with them
and they all get fucking pilled up
together that this is what they argued
over.
Make me hard.
So this is the.
I got to keep this sign because it was
useless because we had to change the
sign to make me stiff.
Like it's okay to pull out your fucking
Dick.
It's okay to have a guy strapped to a
chair thinking a chick is on top of them
and this chick pulls out this wrinkled,
poisoned black Dick.
That's okay,
but you can't call it hard.
You have to call it stiff.
It's really that dumb.
It seems like I would be exaggerating,
but that's why Dave Chappelle walked
away from the Chappelle show.
It's just because having.
When you're a comic,
having somebody else tell you what's
good and what's bad.
Like there was one of the things we did
in the man show where we want to.
Joey ideas.
If you don't know what Joey Diaz is,
his,
uh,
twitter is mad flavor.
One word at mad flavor.
And Joey Diaz is one of the funniest
dudes I've ever met in my life.
He's one of the funniest human beings to
ever live.
And Joey was like 350 pounds.
He's down to 300,
but back then it was like 3:50
and he would always get naked.
We get naked all the time,
getting naked onstage.
And his balls literally look like
grapefruit.
And an old ladies pantyhose.
I mean they're fucking ridiculous and he
doesn't shave them,
but they have no hair on him.
Like he has no hair on his arms,
no hair on his chest.
And he's fat as fuck.
And we wanted to have him introduce us
at the beginning of every show.
He kicks open this door and comes out,
yell,
and let's get this party started.
And his balls and Jangling.
It's fucking hilarious.
First of all,
it's hilarious because Joey's hilarious,
no matter what he could read,
Doug Stanhope said Jody is could read
the phone book and it'd be fired than
most of the shit you see late night tv
and that's totally true,
but they were like,
that's not funny.
What's funny about this,
this is not funny.
No one's going to lie.
It was like a big argument and I said,
listen,
let's do two openings.
Will do one regular opening and then
we'll do one opening with joey.
Well,
we did the opening with joey and they
went fucking crazy.
Of course everybody was screaming and
laughing and it set the tone.
The tone that we wanted to have like
this is we're just trying to have fun.
We're not,
you know,
we're not trying to be relevant or what.
We're just trying to have something that
people enjoy.
Let's have fun.
Let's have a fucking good time.
But it was almost impossible to try to
have that good time.
When you have,
you know,
other people like that aren't
necessarily funny at all and they're
like putting their input into what's
what should be in this comedy show.
So Doug and I got fucked,
but the most important thing is that we
had a good time and we came.
Well,
we were always good friends,
but we became great friends.
All right.
What else was going on here?
The snowflakes.
What?
You don't like the snowflakes to
dragging the video stream down.
Oh,
you know what?
You might be right dude.
The snowflakes might be fucking us.
No more snow flakes.
Is that better everybody?
I'm sure it's bad.
My fucking.
My Internet's gay.
You need to upgrade that.
I can't believe you have.
You haven't done that.
I live used to be on top of the game I
live in.
I know you.
He.
He used to have the fastest Internet
back when the Internet was,
you know,
28 k,
56.
K used to have one back.
When did not.
I asked the ice isdn first.
Then I got a t one line installed in my
house where I'm 56 k modem for business.
Those lines,
I mean they only had of their businesses
and uh,
I live a way the fuck outside of La and
um,
it took a long time for us to get like
Dsl and shit out here.
Like I couldn't get cable.
I used to have to get a satellite
DIRECTV.
So,
so they,
um,
they,
the only thing they have that was really
fast,
this thing called a t one line,
but it was a thousand bucks a month that
goes on news radio.
I was like,
I was totally new rich,
you know,
I was like,
okay.
So when that happened,
when I was like,
okay,
let's do it,
thousand bucks a month,
come on.
And so I got this crazy super fast
internet pipe installed in my house,
but now I got this gay dsl that's just
not very powerful.
I need to upgrade.
I'm going to get some of that at.
And t uverse loving what else we got
here.
Much better.
So much better.
Thank you.
Good.
Awesome.
Because once you get that,
then that's why I asked you get a Wifi
check the dude in the background for a
pulse.
It might be a vampire
team.
Jacob fuck is going on with America.
We have rock stars that don't fuck the
Jonas brothers.
We've got vampires.
Don't buy it.
Anyway.
We have pop stars that can't go to
sleep,
so they,
they,
they get literally said dated every
night we have Golfer's getting fucked.
We got to America.
That's freaking out because an ugly rich
guy is getting a lot of pussy,
a cheat on his wife.
He's his wife.
He's a black athlete.
Like,
is that really a big shot?
I didn't say ugly.
It's amazing that a guy like that,
all he has to do is be good at something
and acquire a bunch of numbers and he
could fuck all these girls.
Like he's sending the pain.
These girls.
It's incredible because one of the girls
was like asking for money and he's like,
I can't help you.
It's like she's not even paying them.
So he's just like billionaire dude,
and he's banging these cocktail
waitresses and they're struggling with
their bills and he wanted to go over any
cash.
Like how hard would it be for tiger
woods?
It just slipper 10 grand.
You know what,
what's the big deal?
She,
she lets you fucker like,
do you have a mirror in your house?
Like you're getting something out of
this man.
You get to fuck her.
And all he wanted was to just give them
Dick like that's all you get.
You get Dick,
you don't get no money.
On one hand I got to say the dude had a
very strong pimp pant,
you know,
the,
I,
I of respect that.
But on the other hand I would feel like
maybe you should give her some money.
Maybe she wouldn't be making a tell all
book if you were like really nice to her
and she gave you.
Gave her the money that she needed.
Yeah.
Tiger is handsome.
So it says gay man Cintas is tigers
handsome?
Okay.
You know what?
He's not ugly,
but he's not like,
it's not.
Jacob Looks Kinda like a bug.
He's not a handsome man.
He's unfortunate looking,
you know?
I mean
he's very well built.
He's very athletic.
He's obviously very driven.
He's got a lot of attractive qualities.
Uber successful.
But you can't say that he's,
you know,
I mean like whose class?
They don't like your guys.
You don't like your guy's black.
Sure I do.
Was like that Tyrese Dude,
that actor dude,
that's a very handsome man.
That's a handsome motherfucker.
If you found out that he was banging 16
checks across the country,
you'd be like,
that's it.
I'm going to figure you out fucking 10
in each talent he was plowing.
That guy's a stud,
you know?
But Tiger doesn't look like that.
Tiger doesn't agree on male model.
He looks like an unfortunate mix of
ethnicities.
Hey,
but you know,
whatever,
whatever.
Hey,
look,
band out.
Please look on that dude from Kroll.
Oh No.
The movie crawl.
You know,
where's the fucking shit that a
pan's labyrinth thing that had the eyes
and it scans that were mode del Toro.
Dude,
it's pretty bad ass.
But I got to say his book sucks.
The strain.
A really good book for like the first
100 pages and then either tired of
writing.
It just fucking just finished it like
real sloppy,
like really bad action scenes.
Really killing the vampires like so
easy.
It was really stupid.
It was really good.
At the beginning I was like,
what a great premise.
The fucking airplane lands.
Everybody in the plane is dead.
They can't figure out what's going on.
And the alternative vampires that takes
over the whole city,
it's pretty bad ass is one vampire like
infected the whole plane.
But then it just turns into dog shit.
Most of the 16 holes aren't that
attractive.
This man is saying that,
that,
that guy was not being pretty girls.
He had a few stragglers in there,
but overall those chips are pretty God
damn hot.
You know better than what that person's
getting.
This guy right here,
he might be getting,
but I mean some of them like that.
Rachel Uchitel check that shakes hot as
fuck.
And then the other one that was on the
reality TV,
she's pretty God damn hot too.
He had some pretty,
pretty attractive women in a stable.
What's jody is twitter game?
Mad Flavor.
Good.
See,
this is one of the things that we can
do.
You can hit this text,
add any texts,
and so if anyone ever asks you,
you can just take the info.
Here we go.
I'll tell you.
Follow and red band.
I know you have a thousand yet.
You don't know her?
I never on my twitter.
Oh yeah.
You guys got to follow red band and then
you could shrink the size and font size.
Yeah.
If you just drag the thing left and
right.
There we go.
Then you can move the box.
They may made it to the top or
something.
That's wherever their location is or the
bottom
doesn't want to move.
You just click on the box and then drag
it.
Okay.
Do the other way.
You wouldn't do it.
Rarely.
Hip position and then just dry.
Won't let me do that black box.
I.
No,
it won't let me grab.
Oh,
there we go.
You fucking pitch
golden news radio or a factor.
Which show was more disgusting to work
on.
Fear factor for sure.
But fear factor paid more money,
but newsradio was way more fun.
News radio was a news.
Radio was like a privilege,
you know?
I was like,
what?
The whole time I was doing his art,
Kenny believe,
first of all,
I couldn't believe that I was on a TV
show that was just like.
Because I didn't,
I didn't really do much acting before
that.
I acted on one other sitcom that I got
from doing standup comedy and in
Nineteen Ninety four I've only been
doing comedy six years,
so it's like I was still pretty raw as a
comedian and then all of a sudden I'm on
this fucking TV shows like,
Whoa,
now I'm on the show.
Not only am I not a TV show,
I'm on a TV show with Phil Hartman,
and I was like,
this is fucking nuts,
you know?
And,
and Dave Foley and Andy Dekoman,
it's pretty incredible job.
But a fear factor was just about getting
clean,
getting there.
You know what I'm saying?
She ain't gonna just like King Mo says,
get that pipe.
Brittany Murphy.
Thoughts you don't want me to.
I don't have any thoughts until I find
out what children,
you know.
I mean everybody says that it's drugs.
I don't know if it was drugs.
I don't think the husband doesn't want
to have an autopsy.
Kinda strange.
Really strange.
You know,
obviously they were going to do one
anyways because it's kind of like wide
sheet.
Hi.
Yeah.
Unless you killed her.
I mean why isn't she?
Why doesn't that guy wanted an autopsy.
If it was a murder case,
then of course he would want an autopsy.
Right.
You'd be like,
how do you dive natural?
The only time where you die of natural
causes when you're 32 years old is if
you have like a serious health condition
or if you take something that kills you,
which is pretty natural.
Right.
I've read that,
that a lot of her close friends stopped
hanging out with her when she got
married to that guy because of him.
So there's something with this guy.
I've had some friends that have had some
serious drug problems in the past.
I had a friend that died from drugs.
My best friend when I lived in New York
and he used to do heroin when he used to
do crack,
but mostly heroin and he had like
manageable problems with coke and stuff
like that.
Until he got on heroin and heroin just
fucking sealed his fate.
That shit,
that shit just gets in your blood.
It becomes a part of you.
I mean,
I've seen people,
Jones and fur coat.
I've seen people Jones for a lot of
shit,
but there's something really weird about
watching people Jones for heroin
immediately.
It's like they need water like during
the desert and they need water and when
people get involved in this,
and apparently that's what a lot of the
Hollywood kids are doing.
A lot of them are doing fucking heroin,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know what it's all about,
but it's pretty spooky,
man.
Real alcoholics are pretty tricky to
like when you wake up and you're 90,
the first thing you drink isn't beer.
Yeah.
I've,
I've met a lot of alcoholics.
I know a lot of alcoholics.
I know a lot of functioning alcoholics
and I know a lot of people that are
just,
you know,
just flat out drunks,
especially comics,
you know,
I've done a lot of comics that have had
real alcohol problems because they get
free booze and they're out in clubs
every night and you know,
alcohol gives you liquid courage and if
you're performing every night,
you might be drinking every night or
you're drinking every night.
You're gonna have a fucking problem.
Eventually.
That shit's going to grab you.
Conspiracy theories are only theories
until proven fact.
Yeah,
all the.
There are real conspiracies.
Most conspiracy theories are stupid
because people want to find the mystery
shit.
They want to find big foot.
You know when.
Meanwhile there's a bunch of real live
animals that are way more interesting
than bigfoot.
If big foot,
if we found big foot,
big foot would be in a fucking cage
right next to the monkeys at the zoo.
If we found them,
if we really caught them,
they be like,
look,
there's a big ape.
You know,
we've got the short eight.
There's a big,
there's a big 10 foot tall ape.
Nobody would give a shit,
but like killer whales,
killer whales didn't exist and there was
some animal that people talked about in
legend that was as smart as people lived
in the ocean,
but breathed air and had to come up for
air and doesn't eat.
Human being saves human beings,
but kills everything else,
including great white sharks.
A superintelligent being it's gigantic
and murderous and runs the ocean.
People would say,
fuck that.
That's crazy.
That's not,
that's not real.
That can't be real,
but it is real.
We just know it's real and because of
the fact that we know it's real,
it's not as interesting to people.
People love mysteries.
We love discovering new shit.
Like the loch ness monster,
loch ness monster doesn't do shit.
It doesn't kill anybody.
It doesn't do anything every now and it
pokes his head out of the water numbers
like,
Whoa,
I saw it and everybody gets crazy.
You know?
Meanwhile,
there's fucking crocodiles that are
real.
They're alive.
They're gigantic to like fucking 30 feet
long.
They can hold their breath underwater
for like hours at a time.
You don't have to eat for a year.
I mean,
crocodiles are fucking crazy.
They're literally dinosaurs that are
still alive today.
They will be exactly the same way as
they are now hundreds of millions of
years ago.
Nobody gives a fuck.
Everybody's looking for the loch ness
monster.
You know,
there's something that people really,
really get into when it comes to
conspiracies,
you know,
and I've been guilty of it myself,
like I used to really be into Ufos and
all kinds of stuff like that until I
kind of realized like what I'm into is
the unknown.
What I'm into is like somehow or another
is if there's something that's unknown
and I figured it out and I find it and I
know it's proven and true.
Then somehow or another you gained
something from that.
I guess you do to a certain extent if
you can really prove it,
but mostly what it is,
this weird desire that human beings have
for things to be to,
to prove things.
So it's a very weird thing.
Conspiracy theories,
like everybody's always looking like for
all sorts of conspiracies that aren't
real.
I know this also from working where I've
had people like working with the UFC,
like people are always talking about the
UFC wants this,
and Joe Rogan said that because of the
UFC told them saying the UFC never tells
me to say shit.
They don't.
They literally never tell me what to
say.
My John's the craziest job ever.
I'm literally the guy who speaks for
this multi hundred million dollar sports
company and nobody tells me what to do.
I show up and they tell me what the
fights are and I just do it.
I try to be professional as possible.
I try not to swear.
Occasionally I'll slip up with that,
but I'm trying not to swear,
but all I'm trying to do is do
commentary on the fights.
The only thing they've ever told me what
to do is when they were trying to by
pride and pride,
fuck them over and there's this big
thing going on back and forth.
They said,
don't please don't mention pride by
name.
You can mention all the fighters,
but don't mention pride by name because
they didn't want to give advertisement
to that organization,
which totally is totally legitimate.
Totally makes sense to me,
you know,
but they don't tell me like,
height this guy up.
Talk about that guy.
Don't,
don't mention this guy's name and make
sure you tell everybody that this guy,
this is the guy we want to win.
There's none of that.
There's no zero.
So I know that's a conspiracy that
people think is real.
That's not real.
I know,
I know there's,
there's a lot of other ones that people
think it's real,
but there's ones that are real.
You know,
I came to.
I are the ones that I've recently turned
on.
Yes.
The whole thing.
You talked about the.
Yeah,
the hair.
There's a lot of people that would look
at those things in the sky and go,
what is that?
What are they doing?
Well,
well I talked to a pilot and I asked to
pilot about it and he gave me a very
simple explanation about how water going
through those jets,
those jet engines at a certain altitude
with certain,
you know,
weather conditions,
certain moisture,
humidity,
made any barometric pressure.
There's all sorts of factors,
but if it's the right factors is enough,
enough water in it,
it'll create clouds.
Like literally jets create cloud.
So all these people like,
man,
they're making clouds.
Well that's what happens when jets fly
through the fucking air.
Like the idea that they won't be grain
cities poisoning people.
So I don't,
they live on the ground to.
They're spraying themselves,
their families and stuff.
They have shots.
I've taken shots that they don't get
that
say that they don't experiment with
weather,
but the majority of the lines you see in
the air,
definitely.
Yeah,
there's legitimate concerns about like
that heart program,
whether they're fucking doing things to
the ionosphere and there's for sure
they're experimenting with whether.
Because we know that China has
successfully created rain,
you know,
they,
they've done successful whether
operations.
So there's,
there are absolutely real conspiracies,
but there's a lot of goofy ones man.
And the problem is it's very difficult
for people to,
once they have made a decision about
something like jfk,
you know,
Oswald acted alone and people just get
that in their head,
Oswald acted alone.
It's very difficult for them to look at
contrary evidence and take it into
consideration.
Like they,
they,
it's almost like there's a competition
going on.
They want their side to be right and
people have a real hard time in our
friend that we were talking about with
the country.
I was,
didn't want to be like we're having an
argument with him while saying,
listen man,
you don't know the research that I've
done.
I'm like,
you're watching youtube clips is that
constitutes research these days,
you know?
And he was convinced the chem trails are
real and I'm like,
they make no sense.
And the other thing that pilot had,
that was a good point,
it was like he's a pilot and he was
like,
believe me man,
pilots would be talking about it.
It wouldn't be like something that's
that easy.
You can just hire a guy to fucking spray
every city in the world everyday of the
week and they're gonna keep their mouths
shut,
class.
All these recorders that are like
getting pissed off at like oil
businesses for ripping off customers.
What if you were getting sprayed with
poison when that reporter be crazy?
It researched reporter
this silly.
That's I think chem trails or a silly
one.
Not not to say they haven't sprayed
people before.
Not to say that there haven't been some
experiments where they've sprayed a
certain bacteria or certain colds,
you know,
over an area to see if they can get
people sick.
What,
why not?
We know there's a thing called operation
midnight climax.
Then in the 19 fifties,
the CIA ran fucking brothels.
They ran whorehouses in New York and San
Francisco and they ran these things and
what they did was they ran a whore house
so they can do lsd experiments on people
and so they unknowingly gave these
John's acid so these poor guys would go
in there just to try to give their,
you know,
their hard earned money.
You know,
they probably didn't even have much
pages,
whatever they had to get their dick
sucked and they're getting dosed with
acid,
freaking the fuck out,
probably already feeling super guilty.
Probably half of them were married and
they just cheat and otherwise and they
felt guilty about that and then they're
dosed up with acid and deal with the
reality of the situation mean we know
the CIA did that.
This is information that was released to
the freedom of Information Act.
You look it up,
Google it.
It's pretty interesting.
It's called operation midnight climax
and it's just one of many experiments
that the CIA did unknowingly on American
citizens taxpayers or they've done it
forever and that's how they do business
and guaranteed that if they did this
back in 1950,
they're doing something like it now.
It's not like they changed.
It's not like these.
All these conspiracies,
all these things that the government's
done like operation northwoods
operation.
Northwoods was the thing that they
propose the 19 sixties,
1962,
and this was signed by the Joint Chiefs
of staff and then vetoed by Kennedy and
what it was was they were trying to get
people enthusiastic about a war against
Cuba,
so they were planning on blowing up
American ships like real ships that
we're going to have mock mock plane
crashes where they're going to blow up
drones in the air and they were going to
blame it on the Cubans.
They were going to say that all these
people died and they were going to take
the passengers and put them under false
aliases and have pilots under false
aliases and that pilot was going to give
may days and say,
you got shot down.
Look that up too.
It's really interesting.
It's called operation northwoods and
this was a real plan that they had
drafted in the 19 sixties that the
Department of defense drafted up and the
the joint chiefs of staff signed and
Kennedy vetoed it.
And Kenny was like,
you guys are fucking crazy.
Like,
what are you doing?
Like you're going to fake attacks in
order to get people to want to go to war
with Cuba,
and that's probably one of the reasons
why they joke Kennedy,
you know,
one of those.
But this is,
these are real conspiracies.
They're real.
We know that their things are conspired
on.
The real problem with conspiracies is
nobody wants to look stupid.
And when you say that you believe
something like you believe in alien
abduction,
or you believe the government killed
Kennedy or you believe you know
anything,
nobody.
We didn't land on the moon.
When you say you don't believe nutty
things,
people just automatically label you a
kook and instead of looking at it and
going,
okay,
what has the government done?
They really have dosed people with lsd
without their knowledge.
They really set up whorehouses the
government.
The CIA did this really.
They really were faking attack.
They were planning a fake knee attacks
on American civilians and blowing up
American ships and blaming on the
Cubans.
They really were going to attack,
wanted them obey attack soldiers.
They were going to fucking shoot mortars
into Guantanamo Bay.
They're going to kill American soldiers
and blame it on the Cubans and get us to
attack them.
That's all real.
So you gotTa Keep Your Eyes Open.
You got to keep your mind open.
And the problem with conspiracy theories
is people choose one side or the other.
Either there's a conspiracy,
theories are ridiculous and I'm not
believing this.
Or they go,
well,
the conspiracies are real and it's
usually not that black or white.
It usually takes a lot of looking at
before you get to the real truth.
And the real truth is fucking sketchy.
I mean it's,
it's real hard to have information about
a lot of things in this world,
as much information as we have on the
Internet.
There's still a lot of shit that you
don't get.
Like Bill Maher,
twittered something today that I was
like,
this guy doesn't even he,
he's incorrectly.
This is all been disproven.
He twitted something,
an anti Christian thing about a Mithra
and you know,
I was like,
how funny it says,
Bill Maher's it.
Even doing this research,
like he's twittering something that
everybody says about Mithra,
but it was disproven.
It gets his knees by the paper.
Here it is.
Mithra born 12 slash 25.
12 disciples died,
rose on May,
on the third day,
perform miracles.
No one has a lamb.
The way,
the truth,
the light 600 years before Jesus Christ.
I see what this point is.
His point is,
what he's trying to say is like,
Hey,
there was no,
you know,
there wasn't.
There was no Jesus Christ.
Now this,
this fable,
this myth has existed in many different
forms,
but the Mithra thing is totally wrong
because the myth or thing,
if you just google a Zeitgeists,
the movie debunked.
This guy gets really into the mythology
behind,
um,
you know,
in Zike guys,
they talk about how Jesus really is the,
basically the same story as all these
different stores before.
And one of them was Mithra and you know,
so,
so bill Maher,
quoting on his thing that Mithra was
born 12 slash 25,
he had 12 disciples.
Well,
if you go to this other site that,
that this guys seems like a really
intelligent guy.
I don't know if he's right,
but he's talking about anybody's
researched at at least talking about the
missing alleged of Mithra are numerous,
numerous in account and span several
different cultures.
I ran,
he says I ran into a brick wall of sorts
trying to track down any of this
information.
I cannot find any evidence of his
birthday being December 25th.
The only dates that correspond to him or
his festival on October eighth and
another on September twelfth through
16th.
A cattle pairing festival October
twelfth through 16th.
There is absolutely is important part.
There is absolutely no evidence anywhere
that he had 12 disciples or 12 of
anything for that matter.
No,
Mithras scholars seem to know about it.
He was not born to a virgin but rather
out of solid rock.
So I mean it's really,
really interesting.
People like,
you know,
there's not,
there's not enough research of
information.
People don't really look these things
up.
They,
they quote a little bit of something
they saw on the Internet and that's the
problem is there's no.
There's no way you can have access to
everything.
There's no way you can know about
It's impossible,
so there's gonna be a lot of shit that
you're,
you're talking about,
you form an opinion on when you're
really just talking out of your ass and
that's where most people are when it
comes to conspiracy theories.
You know,
everything with everything.
People talk out of their ass and because
people have a huge vested interest in
being correct about things.
You know,
people hate being foolish.
They hate being the dumb one.
They hate being uninformed.
You know,
people love correcting people they love
like your is u Apostrophe r,
e as in you are okay.
You're a fucking awesome dude because
you spotted that guy.
Meanwhile I'll do that all the time.
That's Kinda fun.
Being an asshole.
That's kind of why I like the iphone,
how it.
I've always fucks up my texting and
stuff like that because then people are
starting to slowly less do it to me now
because everyone's doing it.
A conspiracy theory with Jesse Ventura.
I haven't seen it.
I haven't even.
Brian didn't like it.
It was all right.
I don't know.
Jesse Ventura is one of them.
Student thinks just because he's a navy
seal or he's a former navy seal that he
has inside information.
I'm a former neighbors,
so you'll
that opie and anthony.
Things just really got to me on both
sides.
Yeah.
You were upset at Jim Norton when you
think of that was on both sides.
That got me upset.
I thought they both handled.
It's hard having a fucking intelligent
conversation.
Seven o'clock
in the morning.
God Damn it.
You know,
whenever I do those morning radio shows,
like what am I even talking about?
Like most half out of it,
mumbling and shit.
It's hard to wake the fuck up.
It's like you have to drink coffee.
If you're going to do one of those
morning radio shows,
you really can't go and sober.
You gotta have a little bit of that.
And a cup of coffee.
Mothra or Rodin.
I was more of a Rodin Fan.
I thought Mothra was kind of a faggy
monster.
Big stupid moth.
That's a dumb.
Here's why I have a giant Roche people.
Ain't roaches.
Roaches are scary as fuck.
Why do you want to have a big stupid
mouth?
You don't.
The Japanese had a bunch of crazy ass
monsters.
They still,
they still do those guys,
you know,
they still draw.
Remember that turtle?
God says,
I wrote and wrote down the turtle.
Turtle.
We won't come on man.
Fucking Pearl.
Do the Godzilla movies with the people
in the classroom.
I heard they still make them in Japan.
We have no confirmation.
See,
this is another,
another thing that I would talk him out
of our ass.
We don't really have.
We've done no research.
No
sick.
So now what that means,
what does sick,
what happens to the iceman?
Now you know,
I don't know man.
I don't know if I.
If I type on this,
is this going to go to my twitter
account?
It's going to quit.
Okay,
so how do I tell people to follow us on
this thing?
You can add new.
You can add new chat boxes or even on
twitter.
Yeah,
I'm going to post this on twitter.
You get people to follow up when you
post on here.
It automatically makes the link.
It does,
yeah.
See?
See how everyone has this link.
Your link underneath it.
Is that cool?
Okay,
what is this?
Hey,
Joe Rogan.net.
What does that,
uh,
that's just what you don't have to quit.
Hey,
Joe Rogan.net.
Okay.
You can erase all that.
That's for other people.
So they don't get nervous when you put
sick and like commas are referring.
Does that mean kind of or like
approximate later?
Excuse me.
When people write sic sic.
Oh,
spelling and correct.
it's when someone uses poor grammar or
spelling.
All this time I've had it mixed.
How high am I right now?
Once 10 for probably before the end of
the.
Not Very High
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
There's 230.
You motherfuckers in here right now.
We're rolling strong bitches.
Two hundred 30.
Merry Christmas.
Merry Christmas to all of you.
Right.
What else might have a friend of Jeet
Kune Doe.
I'm a fan of Bruce Lee.
I'm a fan of his idea,
his idea to add all the martin.
I mean he was really the original mixed
martial artists when I started out as a
kid.
I was,
I did karate and then I started doing
taekwondo and each one of those
disciplines,
karate and taekwondo,
they wanted you to think that their
style was the best style,
the end all be all style karate.
They didn't want you training with
taekwondo people,
taekwondo people.
They didn't want you to train training
with karate people,
you know,
judo people didn't want you to training
with Kung food people.
It was like everybody was like really
attached to their style.
So really Bruce Lee and she couldn't go.
That's the original mixed martial art.
That's the original guy to look at,
you know,
all the different systems and take
what's useful about from each one.
I mean,
Bruce Lee was a.
He was a genius when it came to martial
arts.
Way,
way,
way ahead of his time.
I like this because the questions are
slower.
Twitters and yeah,
this is pretty cool.
This is the first time I've done this.
Like I said,
I'm,
I'm always threatening to do this,
but we're doing it now.
You mother fuckers sub diverter.
Talk more about hunter s Thompson.
I love that feeling.
Where the truth just hits,
you know,
honors Thompson was a fucking genius.
He was a,
he was one of the very few dudes that
really captured the angst of the sixties
and the seventies,
that Nixon era and you know,
the,
he was a part of the acid culture of the
sixties.
He was a part of the culture,
like the San Francisco Haight Ashbury
movement where it's like everybody was
doing acid.
All these people were like and good
acid.
So all these people were like really
coming together and they really like
releasing their egos and their cell,
their identity and kind of like losing
themselves in a movement.
And then this,
this hippie movement of the sixties,
which seems like really stupid.
Now we look at it,
it's like God,
look at these idiots with her long hand
or stupid clothes.
But what they were doing was they were,
they were radically departing from the
previous culture.
I mean the difference between the
fifties and the sixties is fucking
gigantic.
The difference between like buddy holly
and Jimi Hendrix is like,
you know,
I mean that's,
that's another world.
I mean that's not like a 10 year
evolution.
That's an evolution that would have
taken hundreds or not.
Maybe not even gotten there at all.
It's almost like you.
They needed the drugs.
They needed acid and mushrooms and pot
pot and they needed all that shit and
heroin to to launch themselves like from
one,
one frequency to the next one and the
sixties were a totally different
frequency when it came to music,
when it came to culture and that set the
stage for what happened in the seventies
and the eighties and we were the really
crappy music that came from the eighties
and some of them in the seventies,
but definitely the eighties.
Like what that is is like this
consciousness,
this incredible music where these,
these people were like really like
tuning into the art of it in the sixties
more sixties.
Music is like classic fucking Shit.
You know that you,
you here today and you go,
God damn,
that's a good song.
It's like they,
they really figured out how to tap into
the real shit.
You know,
the real energy that makes.
That makes art interesting.
That makes art resonate and I think they
did it with drugs and I think that the,
the,
the decline in the seventies and
certainly in the eighties was because
there was like a void left where the,
this,
this tuning in,
this connection to the real pure source
was gone.
You know,
it's like whatever they had hit whatever
frequency they had nailed in the
sixties,
the echoes of it had died down by the
time the eighties head,
you know,
I think hunter s Thompson had a fucking
brilliant story that he wrote,
a brilliant piece that he wrote,
um,
the wave,
the talking about how the sixties,
it's like,
was like,
like a wave and that when the sixties
ended you could see where the wave broke
back,
like where they thought that people
could be like,
where they saw the true potential of,
of humanity,
of the United States,
of the human race in general.
And saw just roll back and go back to
where it was.
And that's what it was between the
sixties and seventies,
you know.
And he nailed that shit better than
anybody.
Hunter s Thompson's words today still
when you look at like especially what
was going on with the Bush
administration and it was just like the
clearest evidence ever have of massive
amounts of corruption in government
where you know,
it's been,
they,
they got us into a war that made no
fucking sense.
I mean,
and it was obvious like across the
board,
the Internet was up,
the information was being,
you know,
very easily transferred back and forth
and yet it still managed to go through
and do the way he felt about the Nixon
administration.
I mean,
you literally could substitute Nixon for
Bush and then insert most of the shit
that he said and to the early two
thousands raw sound as it sounds shitty.
What do,
what do you think about doing a radio
show of my own?
I would love to do radio show.
The only problem is I don't think
anybody wants to pay me to do a radio
show.
I might have to do a radio show like
this because right now,
I mean Adam Corolla has a sweet setup
where he does a podcast and he gets a
lot of people to listen to it and that
might be the way to go because satellite
radio is struggling financially and you
know,
some people make money from it,
like,
you know,
obviously Howard stern makes a lot of
money from it and I think opie and
anthony make good money from it,
but they don't want to pay anybody else.
They're not making money so they don't
have the money to give out.
So I think,
um,
if I'm going to do any sort of a turn
that up was at work.
Is that any better?
Is that lauder anybody?
If I'm going to do any sort of a,
um,
a podcast or something like that,
it's going to be this,
it's gonna be like this.
And I saw soldier boy do it.
So I'll say it again.
Yeah.
Maybe that video through a department.
The guy in the background with this gold
necklace.
Yeah.
Soldier boy is fascinating to me.
If you don't know soldier boy,
he's a rapper,
a very young fellow who's wildly
successful,
made millions and millions of dollars
and he's tattooed his entire body and
liked the course of a few months,
like all the way up his neck and his
face is tattooed and his sleeves and his
chest and everything.
I mean he just tattooed the fuck out of
himself,
but like writing and shit,
like really bad artwork.
Really,
really interesting.
Just I guess he likes it
crazy.
How many times a day do you think he
makes it rain?
Makes it rain,
does it all day.
Smalltime multine,
multimillionaire,
and he's only like 19 years old and when
they became rich and famous,
he was only like 17.
He's an interesting little study right
there.
When Kimbo sits all day,
what does it mean?
All debt.
That's what it means.
Making it rain all day.
No,
it doesn't mean making.
When Kimbo says,
all Kimbo says all dates means he's
fucking dudes up all day.
This is how we do it,
and he holds up the dukes.
I got some pretty fucking sweet Kimbo
slice t shirts that I just got from my
buddies.
A tap out.
They're upstairs though.
Show me your drunk.
My drawings.
I'm going to actually put those online
too.
It's pretty bash.
Have put those.
He just found his old drawings from when
he was younger and they're amazing.
It's some shit that I,
uh,
I made when I was a little kid when I
was,
well,
not a little kid.
I was like 18.
See twit pic.
Do,
do,
do.
Oh,
I can choose a picture from here.
Yeah.
Put it up.
I'll put it up in my twitter word.
I was pretty blown away.
He's really good at drawing and he has
these two drawings.
He did are just amazing.
I mean,
I thought I was good back in the day,
but he blows me out of the water back in
the day.
Whereas I never used a technical
candidates part.
He's checking the pens are awesome.
Yeah,
that's pretty.
You would
love it.
When I,
I,
um,
first started
out when I was a kid,
I was really into comic books.
I wanted to be a comic book artist.
Big Bad wolf three.
Oh,
cool.
You already scanned it.
Was scanned it uploaded.
Tweet float.
It's uploading.
Um,
when I was a fuck.
Everything up my gay service.
It's so slow.
Look how slow this is because there's a
big ass picture.
It's like three megs.
Two megs.
A second charter.
Yeah.
I gotta I gotta switch.
You tweet stuff to you or use the chat.
Oh,
tweet stuff to me,
man.
Don't many people to chats that shit.
Ain't that shit?
Ain't gonna work.
Tracy Lee just sent me a text message.
You guys know Tracy Lee from Dana was in
the chat.
You missed it.
Oh,
Dana was in the house.
Dana.
She thinks it's a real.
No.
Why do you think it's a real?
Dana?
How dare you?
The Internet.
Can you.
Can I ask?
Cheeseburger got no fucking deal to be
in my goddamn chat.
Quit say you're a bomber.
This,
this time.
All right,
tracy.
I got two right here.
And Tracy,
I'm in the shower
to the chat too.
And that wasn't Dana.
You done?
Is Tracy Lee.
She's the combat lifestyle photographer.
Yeah,
this is the best font of all time.
The iphone,
ladies and gentlemen,
you really can't fuck with it.
We've tried every other phone.
I'm A.
I'm a technical fucking Geek.
I'm a nerd.
I love phones,
but there's no phone that can fuck with
the iphone.
There's no network that could fuck with
verizon now and that's the real God damn
problem.
So I don't use the iphone as my main
phone.
I mostly use the iphone these days as
like an internet device.
I use it as like a little tin,
mini laptop and shit,
but from my phone I use one of these
blackberry storm twos,
which as a phone is not nearly as good.
It's kind of funky.
The typing on.
It's not bad.
The storm too is definitely better than
the storm one,
but man,
fucking the network is 100 times better.
The,
the,
the verizon network.
When I had 18 t like when I would drive
to Jujitsu at night,
I drive the same way and it got to go to
Hollywood and my shit would drop out
three times on the way to Hollywood.
Three fucking times in 25,
30 miles,
whatever it is,
three times the shit would drop out with
verizon.
Straight through
never drops out.
It doesn't.
They're about anywhere and I get better
reception inside buildings.
It's just like better.
It's just better reception period and
it's not like a little bit better.
It's like several times better,
you know,
it's like the amount of dropbox that I
get with verizon are so tiny in
comparison to the ata and t eight t and
t just,
they just got fucked by that iphone.
That iphone is overloaded,
their network overload,
that shit out of it
and the things that they just dropped
something that 18 has been pushing
lately,
but I and I agree is not being able to
use your data network while you're on
the phone.
Verizon,
you can't.
When you're on the phone,
you can't check your email and get new
email or go on twitter and get new
twitter's while you're on the phone.
You can't use your data and your phone
together at the same time.
Did you know that?
No,
I didn't know that.
That's huge.
That's bigger than a dropped call once
in a while I think.
Yeah,
that is bigger.
You'd have no idea what I'm talking
about.
No data and not being able to use data.
And if you're on the phone you can't
get,
you can't get a emails while you're on
the phone.
Good.
And Verizon can't fix that with your
current network.
Yeah,
that's great.
That's why they had that thing where
they show that you can get on the phone
and go into the apps.
The but that sucks.
It does suck,
but I'll take being able to use the
phone over that.
I like using the phone.
I like what I'm driving.
I get my business done,
you know what I'm saying?
A dry.
I have to get shit done and I have to
talk to people and sometimes I have
conference calls.
Sometimes they'll do interviews while
I'm driving my car,
you know,
you know like you will call me up and
you'll say something like,
what's that?
How do you do this?
Or something like come on,
they'd be gone.
I can't go.
You can't do any.
That's what it is.
Weak.
But I'll take it,
I'll take that and have a signal.
I'll take not being able to do both at
the same time and have a strong signal.
Right.
I'll take that.
And that's because the cdma can't handle
two streams at the same time.
It is,
right?
Well,
verizon actually uses older technology.
The TDX is a newer technology,
which is verizon.
It's kind of an avenger in trouble.
They have a slower network.
It's,
it's,
uh,
can't handle those two things at once.
Yeah.
But it still works better.
We'll take it right.
Forgy a isn't out yet here.
Somebody wrote.
Soldier boy is a fucking Douche.
Listen,
do you think you would be any better if
you were 19 years old and he's worth
like millions?
Yeah.
Yes.
It's huge on the Internet though.
He's showing you some money and send a
19 year old kid that's worth millions of
dollars.
Like literally.
Yeah,
you can't.
We would both be.
I would be retarded was when I was 19
because the Jonas brothers are
hypnotized by Walt Disney.
Yes.
They drank the Disney koolaid.
Yep.
Didn't even get pussy.
What's the point in being rich and
famous if you're not even getting laid
right?
It's ridiculous.
We got rock stars.
Don't fuck they.
Fuck they fucked.
Now when they get married,
Ms Dot Tracy leads in here.
She says the sound is fine.
Everybody that's in that chat.
Get the fuck out of there because I'm
not paying attention.
That shit.
Tweet it.
You dirty bitches.
How come the tweet isn't updating?
You're getting too many tweets per hour
and really probably you probably have to
go because this thing's open.
You see to two programs are taking your
apis.
Okay.
All right.
I'm going to shut shut.
Shut this one off.
I would shut that one.
All right.
I'm shutting tweet deck off by tweet
deck.
All right,
let's.
I'm just trying to optimize here because
like I told you guys,
I've got a terrible Internet connection,
but I'm not getting my goddamn
twitter's.
So let me update this bitch right here.
I've done.
Oh,
here we go.
All right.
You know what?
What?
What'd you get your updated internet?
We'll get you into an hd camera too.
The pope got laid out by a crazy woman.
I didn't think it was a pope.
I think it was some,
some,
some crazy chick try to attack the pope,
but some other dude who is in government
got hit in the face with a statue in
Italy.
What does this.
They put an ad in front of us and they
put advertising what?
The newest thing they put some.
Some are,
what are we advertising?
This is because I was talking about
soulja boy.
Is that really a soldier?
Boy?
No.
Soulja boy's home leaves.
They're just chilling.
Shit out my money.
Look at all my new sneakers.
Even the bottom of my sneakers is clean.
That's bullshit.
It's bullshit.
They're advertising.
Please.
Everybody Click close on that
advertisement.
Fucking it.
Don't God damn heat and the close button
is.
It's raised the upper lower,
upper left corner.
If you see that.
That's right.
Close that close.
That shit.
Fucking advertisement.
That's one bad thing about use string
because I don't remember Justin TV
having that do that.
Justin TV.
It's about to get in trouble with a
Justin TV is getting in trouble or
something.
They were mentioning that UFC or they're
in trouble.
Well there it's obvious if you have a
thousand like Justin TV supposedly
working with the people that are owning
the copyright material,
why wouldn't it be easy if you noticed
that one of your chat rooms went from
zero to 2002nd,
you know,
delete,
delete.
Well,
like I said,
you can't fly the Internet.
People gonna figure out a way to put
things online.
They're just going to.
I thought that was the real problem was
that people were taking a copy of it
after the event and then uploading it,
but that's not what the problem is.
Problem,
promise,
streaming,
promise.
If you have any streaming,
you're going to have power.
Does dreaming.
Yeah.
We can't stop that.
I don't think you can stop it.
Maybe you can.
Maybe you can stop it by cutting back on
those sites would probably stop and
substantially,
but that's going to kill those sites.
You know it's going to kill you.
Streams.
Gonna Kill Justin TV is going
to kill the sites like this where you
can just stream anything.
You mother fuckers.
Wow.
Three hundred 64 people.
This is like a comedy club,
Ladies and gentlemen.
It's nuts.
All right,
let's take some questions here and dirty
bitches.
Wow.
There's a lot of God damn what have this
marijuana and it increasing brain cells,
you know,
I don't know if it increases brain
cells.
There's been some research that suggests
that and suggested it also slows down
the progression of Alzheimer's.
I don't know.
It does.
It does a lot of good for you though.
That's what people need to understand.
There's a lot of drugs that are terrible
for you.
Marijuana is not one of them.
Marijuana does a lot of good things for
you.
It calms you down.
It relaxes you.
It makes you take things.
I just got a text from Bruce.
Buffer.
Powerful.
It makes you,
um,
makes you consider other options.
It makes you consider the possibilities.
It makes you think about yourself more.
It makes you think about,
you know,
whether or not you're being a Douche
bag.
You know whether or not you're behaving
the right way.
Marijuana is good for you.
Does it give you extra brain cells?
I Dunno,
I was gonna write the copy of the cover
of my shiny happy jihad.
The first name for that CD was going to
be weed made me smarter.
I was going to call it that,
but I decided that was kinda like that
sentence doesn't sound smart.
Made Smarter.
Yeah.
It's not supposed to be sent to be
funny.
Silly supposed to.
I think that I'm going to do a book
though called weed made me smarter.
I think that's kind of the name of it,
but you know,
because that's like a good name for a
book,
you know,
that's like a grabbed you.
That's something that would grab you.
You'd want to check it out here about
Rick Simpson oil.
Yeah.
It's like how it cures cancer or
assumption.
She not Dan Quann play video games with
my favorite of all time.
Quite A.
I used to have a huge problem.
That's why I got a t one line.
It's called to my house.
I should play quake everyday,
eight hours a day.
Did you watch that video I posted where
they go into the airport and just start
spraying people and intimate what game
is called duty raw,
wherever the new one and then one.
Yeah.
I've never played call of duty.
I don't want to get addicted,
man.
I got problems.
I get addicted to everything.
I get addicted to pool.
I used to play pool eight hours a day
more.
Even sometimes I used to get addicted to
video games.
That's why I'm scared of golf.
I've never played golf.
I'm terrified of that shit because I
know dudes who play golf.
They can't,
they sit around all day and practice
fake swinging.
It's they get addicted,
you know,
and I get very badly addicted to games.
So I try to leave my addictions to
things that benefit me now.
Like so like pool.
I like pool don't play as much as I used
to.
I just fuck around with it.
But like Jujitsu and stand up comedy,
I tried to be more.
I try to be addicted to things that are
um,
beneficial to me instead of things that
are just going to like eat up all my
day,
which is what pool used to be for me.
And what video games used to be for me.
I used to have real fucking problems.
Thank you.
I'm glad you enjoyed the drawing.
I twittered a drawing that I made when I
was,
I think I was like 18 or 19 years old.
Are you still want to be a comic book
artists?
Red Dragons.
Indeed.
Have you seen any pre prefer the new
karate kid movie?
No,
I have not.
It's black karate kid.
They're redoing the karate kid,
but the kid is black and I think it's
will Smith's kid.
Kid.
That's awesome.
Were easy.
Karate is making a comeback,
man.
Leo Machida.
Yeah,
but don't fuck with the karate kid
rounds.
Marijuana would bring California out of
bankruptcy.
Do you really think so?
Don't fuck with the karate kid.
You say that like the karate kid was
like some awesome movie.
Dude.
It's a childhood memory.
They fucked up Gig.
Oh,
they fucked up transformers.
Childhood was she joe,
and it was the worst movie ever known,
but in a main.
Before that movie.
What was it before?
It was a cartoon series.
Cartoons,
right.
They didn't really fuck it up though.
They just made a bad move.
It was horrible.
It was awful.
How fast can Bj Penn,
Bj.
Okay,
man.
I don't know if there's anybody at 1:55.
They can fuck a Bj Penn now.
Now the BJ's taken everything like super
serious and training like a dedicated
athlete.
He's a destroyer at 1:55.
Just nobody that's even close to him.
I mean,
no one's even in his.
His frequency.
He's.
He's in the matrix right now.
You know,
there's certain dudes they get to a
certain point with confidence,
with experience,
with skill technique and then you add
discipline and conditioning to that.
They get to this crazy place that very
few people can reach this crazy high air
and that's where Bj Penn's at right now.
Right Anderson Silva too.
He's another one.
He's just in this air that nobody can
fuck with that.
That's what's good about the ultimate
fighter that because it's kind of
bringing new people in,
unknown people you know,
but you know,
there's such a gigantic gap between
these guys that have fought in these
smaller organizations and the guys at
the top of the food chain and you see
like with fate or million inco,
like it takes so many years for a guy to
become like the fader of today and
Anderson Silva is a perfect example that
I like Anderson Silva when he's fighting
in pride.
I mean he got submitted by Rio,
shown in a to Z.
got them in a mounted triangle.
There's dudes.
Dudes were beating him.
Dudes are submitting him,
you know,
I mean he,
he knocked out,
Carlos didn't,
but he just didn't look like the
Anderson Silva of today.
And he had to have those fights.
You had to have those losses.
You had to get better.
He had to rise,
you know,
he had to really get his shit together,
really focused on his Jujitsu and,
and really become black belts on the
ground.
So he had this full package so that he
was totally confident in throwing
strikes because you didn't worry at all
about being on the ground and that's the
Anderson Silva,
the Ab now just like fully complete
fighter.
But we had to see him evolve.
It took a long time for him to become
the guy that he is today.
And that's what,
you know,
it takes a long time to make a full,
complete mixed martial artist.
And these guys today,
I mean the competition is staggering.
There's so many fighters now.
There's mean there's so many different
organizations,
so many fighters and so many guys are
good.
It's so hard to,
to advance and to,
you know,
to,
to make it to the very top of the food
chain in today's mixed martial arts
world.
I mean it's so much fucking
competitions.
It's amazing.
I mean when I first started doing the
UFC,
I first started working for them in 1997
and it was tiny.
We did the first show and dose in
Alabama.
There was nobody there.
I mean there was like a thousand people
or something like that.
And it's because the tickets were really
cheap and because people came to see a
fucking freak show,
there was nobody there that knew when
someone was passing the guard and nobody
passed the guard back then either.
You know,
nobody knew what the fuck was going on.
Nobody knew,
you know,
the that leg kicks were really bad for
you.
The fuck your legs up.
People would see a guy kicking somebody
in the legs like,
what was he doing that you know,
like back then you were allowed to punch
people in the balls.
You know,
you're able to pull hair.
You had to pull him close.
Was crazy.
The early days to what it is now.
So really fucking amazing.
Your face is amazing.
Your fucking face.
Amazing.
Don Fry retired from MMA.
Don Frye is a fucking real man that
belongs in a movie.
They should make a movie.
And a dom fry is fucking mustache alone.
Is epic.
John Fry's a real man.
Ladies and gentlemen,
a real goddamn man.
Three hundred and 72 viewers.
Okay,
this shit's fun.
They're saying that sounds good,
but I think this sounds better when
we've got close needs to point towards
your face.
Oh really?
Have towards your fucking face.
Face is pointing towards your face were
to float.com.
Is that a website where to float.com.
If you google where to float,
I know you can.
If you want to know about flotation
tanks,
these are what this guy's asking about
is a thing called a sensory deprivation
tank.
And what that is,
is um,
there's a,
a tank filled with water.
If you haven't heard about this before,
you could google it and there's,
there's videos of the we made that you
could find online and Brian made,
if you see any of my videos for my
website and you go,
wow,
those are really cool and creative
describing.
So that's Brian Russell.
He's a fucking video genius.
Bitches recognized.
And uh,
we made a really cool,
one of the explains the isolation tank,
but what it is is a tank of water that
has a 800 pounds of salt in it and the
water is heated to the same temperature
of your skin.
And the salt makes you very buoyant,
so you lie in the water and you float.
And the um,
the fact that the water is heated to the
same temperature as your skin,
you don't feel it.
So you're floating in this water.
You don't really feel the water anymore
because the water in the air and
everything,
it all feels like one thing.
It feels like you're weightless and
you're flying through space.
And when he closed the door in this
thing,
you're in total darkness.
You're in total silence.
Your ears are underwater,
you don't hear anything.
And in the absence of any sensory input,
You don't feel anything.
You don't see anything.
In the absence of all that,
your mind has no distractions.
And your brain becomes supercharged and
you start having vivid hallucinations
and you start like,
it's really like a psychedelic
experience.
You really start,
you,
you start like really like,
uh,
like researching your,
your thoughts and getting to the heart
of who you are separate from culture,
separate from language,
separate from your experiences.
You get down to who you are.
And then when you get to that,
once you get past that as one of the
hallucination start because you kind of
ceased to exist.
As you define yourself as who you are by
your job,
the car you drive,
the house you live in,
the family you have the friends,
you keep,
you define yourself by all these
different things.
But when,
when you're in that tank,
all those things are gone.
There's no,
there's no outside world that is just
the mind,
it's the mind untethered from the body.
And when you're in that state you,
you kinda transverse.
You kind of travel between this
consciousness and this reality to
another one.
You,
you,
you travel outside of this world and you
traveled to this,
the world of the deep inner thoughts,
you know,
the deep inner connection between
whatever the fuck this life is.
You know,
the connection between your
consciousness and the universe and it
gets pretty fucking crazy.
I have one of those bitches in my
basement.
I do it all the time.
Is it like a really great power nap?
No,
it's not like a really great power nap.
It's like a really great mushroom trip,
but the best thing about it is you can
end it at any second.
Anytime you want to end it.
You just open up the door and you're
stone cold sober so you can be in this
deep trance where you're,
you know,
your.
I've had really vivid,
vivid hallucinations in there where I
felt like I was like I had traveled down
to the very atomic structure of human
beings and gotten through the lowest
point and at that lowest point,
as you get lower and lower and deeper
and deeper,
it became like another universe.
And the idea in my head was that all of
this life that we see,
you know,
subatomic particles to Adams to all
these things like this,
this progression of things getting
bigger and bigger and bigger to humans,
to countries to continence the planets,
to planets,
to galaxies,
galaxies to you know,
to universities and that all this idea
that things just keep getting bigger and
bigger and bigger.
Well that it's,
it works infinitely in both directions.
And it was like I was taken on a trip
through the whole experience from
Subatomic to atomic to planets to flying
through space to face space,
being subatomic to the,
you know,
this new Adam that exists and it's a
part of new organisms that exist that
are part of a new ecosystem that exists
that's a part of a new planet that's a
part of a new galaxy that's part of a
new universe.
And it goes on and on and on.
And I went through this whole thing like
over and over again,
like multiple times.
And it was really fucking crazy.
It was a very,
very vivid and very realistic and very,
you know,
very life changing.
The whole thing is like doing it a lot.
You got to do the isolation tank a lot
and you've got to learn to relax and
you've got to learn to give in to the
experience because so many times when
you're in there,
you're thinking about things and you're
worrying about things and you think
about your bills and your bullshit and
you know,
I'm gonna Lose Weight and Oh,
I've got to do this.
And all those thoughts distract you.
It's like the state of mind that you can
achieve in this isolation tank.
It's very similar to the state of mind
that you can achieve from,
you know,
when monks go through,
decades and decades of intense
meditation,
like they achieve the same type of state
of mind,
but you're achieving it like no
discipline.
So it's hard to manage sometimes,
but if you can learn to manage it and if
you learn to go in with the correct
thought process and to approach it the
right way and maybe meditate before you
go in and calm yourself and put yourself
in a good state of mind and know how to
navigate the waters of these
experiences,
then you can get to the crazy part,
the crazy part.
It's hard to get to it,
but it's there.
We should ask them what sounds better
and switch between the three.
Okay.
What sounds better when there's three
settings to this microphone.
This is what sounds better.
This is setting one.
Ready?
Hi,
my name is Joe Rogan.
Okay.
Two.
This is setting to this setting to.
Hi,
my name is Joe Rogan.
Is this better?
Does this sound better to you or setting
three.
Hi,
my name is Joe Rogan.
Does this sound better to you?
Which,
which one?
Sounds better.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please tweet.
Now you're going
no the fuck out of people.
People that have like get your phone
messages.
Like sometimes I'll tweet like I'll get
baked and I watched the Steven Seagal
shell and I'll tweet way too much and I
get a lot of angry tweets from moon.
It's annoying.
It gets annoying if you only fall like
below 100 people or something.
That's why I started falling more and
make it more just like a chat room on
your.
Yeah.
I have thousands of people following
them.
I just hate when people replied,
like every single person that's ever
written him ever wrote them ever.
You know,
replies.
That's a problem
to twitter right now.
Do,
do,
do
one sounds best three.
You Dick.
Three D.
I'm a dick.
One in three are close to Sachs.
One and three.
Close.
Let's do three is louder but one seems
better quality.
So it seems one three than to.
Okay.
It seems like one is the one,
one,
three,
someone yelled out.
One,
one,
one.
Most people are saying it's time between
one three.
So let's go with one.
Alright.
We're gonna at one.
Fuck you and your threes.
Whoa.
Strong.
All right.
How's your Melrose Shogun?
Oh,
a.
I'm going to be at the Melrose Improv.
If anybody's in La,
the Improv on Melrose,
I'm going to be there on New Year's Eve.
Two shows.
I think it's eight and 10 for sure
because I heard one show and then just
on hip hop website they have like an
early time that you can go to eat dinner
ruin.
It looks like a second show,
but it's not really two shows.
Oh,
that's a problem because that's quick.
Yeah.
In Vegas the following day at the House
of Blues?
Yes.
The following day,
January,
First House of Blues,
Vegas,
just pitches and then after that,
Washington DC,
January I think seventh or something
like that.
We know because that's what's up.
Oh no upcoming shows.
This fucking thing sucks.
The improv's website is dog shit.
Joe Rogan dinner.
Ten PM 10.
Oh,
one Joe Rogan show.
Huh?
Say you did it.
It's just saying that it says there's
only one show.
Yeah,
I think they're always only one shot.
I only have it on your website is 1:10
PM.
Ooh,
this is going to be a disaster.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's going to be crazy.
If you want to go to the Improv,
you got to go.
Now it looks like it's already sold out.
There's this whole trying to buy a
ticket right now.
Oh wait,
we tried to buy a ticket right there.
You're still taking.
Okay.
You can still buy tickets,
but get them quick because that pitch is
going to sell out.
Maybe we'll add an 8:00
show.
I don't want anybody to get shut out and
sometimes 8:00
is the move.
You go there,
have a show,
have a good time.
Get your freak on.
Have A,
you know,
have a couple of laps and then go hide
when it comes to midnight so you don't
get bullets drop.
But on your fucking head.
Mullah Douche bags out here,
like the fire guns in the air and get
crazy.
I can handle it.
And they drank and drive and it's very
dangerous.
I got some hilarious video of last new
years there of these old ladies dancing
and stuff.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I wish we had that right now.
We'll get streaming,
right?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm going to upgrade this internet this
week as Internet I got here because then
once I'll bring my laptop and then I'll
start to be able to just send you a
video.
We're going to set it up like a Goddamn
fucking TV studio in here.
Bitch is 358.
I'm losing viewers.
Must be boring.
Answer some questions here.
Adelaide show in Vegas.
Um,
I don't think so.
Man.
Late chosen vegas or a nightmare.
How's it gloves?
Pretty big already.
Yeah.
The House of blues is a good size
anyway.
I want the one thing that I won't do
anymore as I used to do the house of
Blues and I had most of the people were
seated but then there was all standing
room in the back.
But the problem is that standing room by
the bar just becomes a bar and people
just started talking and it becomes a
fucking nightmare.
So no more shows.
I'm not doing any more shows ever
anywhere where people have to stand up
while they're watching show.
And
the reason being is because I went to
see Doug Stan hope when he was in la and
we went to see him and we're standing in
the back of the room because he did a
standing room only show and it was like
after like an hour like your fucking
back hurts.
He starts bothering you and you're,
it's not comfortable to stand up and
watch a show.
I always figured because I'm on stage
standing for an hour,
like it's no big deal,
you know,
you can stand for an hour and a half and
talk on stage and it doesn't feel it's
not a problem,
but standing still watching someone is a
big difference between
worse.
It's terrible.
Do you even remember like the last half
of that show?
Because I was focused on my feet the
whole time.
It's a terrible feeling.
And what's weird is I talked to somebody
in Texas,
they walked out of this show because
they couldn't because it was awkward
standing room only and Doug's show and
they just walked out here like we
couldn't take anymore.
Yeah,
I hate it.
So I'm not doing it anymore.
And I'm having problems with this
because I had a show booked in March at
the fillmore,
the fillmore in New York City.
And they said that the whole balcony he
had to be standing.
I'm like,
fuck,
that man gave me less money.
Let's see what we can.
And.
But they were like,
you know,
we can make more money if people stand.
And I was like,
all right,
you're done.
And so I canceled that Gig.
And then the same thing happened in
Houston.
I was supposed to do the house of Blues
and the same thing.
They were like,
well,
you know,
we can't,
we need to have people standing in the
back.
And I'd had it booked or I don't know.
My agents are not communicating this to
the people or they're not paying
attention.
It's going through too many people
before it gets to the person that makes
the decision,
but they didn't want.
They wanted to have people stand and I
said fuck that.
So now I'm going to have to find a new
gig in New York and new Gig in Houston
and I'm probably going to wind up doing
the Improv in Houston.
I don't know.
Thinking about that and some maybe one
of the clubs in New York City.
You go to Joe's twitter or a website
that has this calendar on it.
You just gained for people.
Those people like talking about
standing.
Yes.
Do you remember standing,
waiting,
like wave for a roller coaster.
Understanding like three hours for a
roller coaster.
Like last minute.
Yeah.
It's fucking terrible.
Why don't like Tom Green?
Yeah.
Tom Green's got an awesome set up.
I went to Tom Green's house where I
filmed a his talk show there and he's
got a fucking crazy setup man,
like giant servers and he's got wires
big,
you know,
wires all throughout his living room
because like he's doing it like serious
hardcore style and he's doing it or at
least back to anyone.
He's still doing it,
isn't he or is he?
Is he straight paper view now that you
can't watch it for free at all now?
I think.
I think
Tom Green live and see that.
Is that the case ladies and gentlemen?
If it is,
I think that's a fucking mistake.
I think it is too.
That's great.
Maybe.
Maybe it's the archives.
You have to be a member to watch.
That makes sense.
Maybe we'll see.
We're going into the channel.
He calls it the channel.
I don't know what that's all about.
Ready to receive stream.
Oh.
Oh,
he's doing comedy episode.
Isn't that crazy?
Questions about membership and
subscription service.
Click here.
Alright,
click here.
Okay.
Welcome to questions about support side
membership.
Full access to a collection of videos.
That's what it is behind the scenes.
Can I cancel it anytime?
Yes.
Five slash $95 a month.
Not a bad price.
Good price.
I wonder if he's making money during
that four.
90 five would have been better than
before.
90 five.
How about just five bucks?
Which would this fucking five shit for
95.
That's stupid man.
That tries to be crazy.
$5.
Ninety nine.
Just tell me it's $6.
You fuck.
So do you open your presents on
Christmas Eve tonight?
We're going to.
Why do you do that?
Does that mean you grew up doing or can
impulsive?
I don't know.
What should I wait?
I'm grown up.
You do it at midnight.
An hour or something?
I better get some good shit too.
That's what I'm saying
is that my parents sent me money and
then I took that money to buy them
presents and actually spent more than
that.
They sent me if I would have waited and
sent them presents first and then they
got me money.
I would have felt like I got something,
but I felt like I just bought them
presence.
It's all about timing,
timing.
You know,
if I sent you money to buy them things
or your personal shopper,
but if I would have stepped in something
first and then got money,
I would've felt like,
oh,
I've got some cash.
Interesting.
Alright.
Thanks for spending Christmas Eve with
us.
You're welcome.
Molly.
I'm going to say people's names when I.
When I read your question.
So you feel like I'm talking to you
because I am.
Were you pissed when he found out there
was no Santa or did you find out there
was no Santa Claus?
I stumbled into my parents' rapping
shit.
Oh really?
I was like,
and then we opened it the next day.
I like what the fuck,
like I hid and I saw them.
Right.
And then I just put two and two
together.
My friend has this video of her daughter
last year and her daughters,
like I saw Santa Claus last night.
He had a beard
and he had a big stomach and had the
belt and the mom's like,
Oh really?
Really?
Can you imagine fucking lie?
I know as you're watching them load
after I would have to correct the kid.
I was like,
listen,
don't lie.
Don't lie.
Stopped.
He would have said that you can't see
sandy's invisible.
Oh,
you can't lie to me.
It makes sense.
She was like,
for three.
She's a liar.
Fucking video though.
I think it's very important to call kids
on being I was a or when I was a little
kid as well.
I'm saying this.
I had a very vivid imagination and not
such a good life,
so it always make up stories and I wish
someone had called me on my bullshit.
Then so when it taken so long for me to
figure it out on my own,
the people knew I was right.
I didn't figure it out.
There was like 10.
Pinocchio would have worked out.
When you're a kid watching Nokia,
I don't want to know some big moves.
He's made a wood wooden.
People can't fucking talk,
right?
It's stupid.
Why did they make about a way upstate
says,
I steal your jokes and I used them as my
facebook messages.
I hope.
I hope it gets you laid.
Does it get you laid?
If it gets you laid,
I approve or give you thumbs up,
sir,
show us your breasts.
How dare you de la Roche.
How dare you may have to keep up with
these twitters.
She fucking.
It's twitter's.
Let's go to those coming in now.
Well,
UFC ever had a 1:35
division.
I think the UFC in the WEC.
The idea is eventually that is going to
be one thing when I don't know,
but I think it should be because I think
guys like Jose Aldo and Uriah Faber and
Mike Brown and Miguel Torres,
those guys are fucking awesome.
They deserve all the attention that the
UFC gets.
They deserve people to,
you know,
to be clamoring for super fights and to
see big paper view bouts in,
you know,
matter in Madison Square Garden and
fucking,
you know,
the,
the mgm grand,
they,
those guys deserve to be at those kind
of shows.
The level of talent in the WEC right now
is staggering.
One hundred and 3,545
pound division mean.
This guys are fucking animals man.
And even 1:55,
they have some awesome fighters.
I think it would be beneficial to
everybody if it was all the UFC was all
one thing,
you know,
especially since they owned the WEC.
I think it would help everybody if they
could make that happen.
If it's possible.
Rigorous Sachs says use that little kid
liar in the act.
I don't know if that's really funny for
sure.
I think that's funny white now because
we're talking about right now,
but I don't know if you could recreate
the.
It's not funny enough to recreate that.
Say It on stage.
Might be.
Might be when you're talking about if my
daughter gets to the age where my,
uh,
have you wrote any new conspiracy theory
kind of comedy lately?
Because I remember you used to be really
big into writing like Noah's Ark.
A mystery.
Yeah.
I've been writing a lot of that shit
lately.
My favorite,
favorite.
She's my favorite shit.
Yeah.
I'm writing more of that shit.
It's like comedy.
My comedy comes in big waves of
creativity.
Williams of inspiration is clay quita.
Okay.
Yeah,
he's okay.
Yeah.
You got cut up Kenny Florian.
Cut Them Up,
put some elbows.
Web beastie.
All right,
what's my take short fuse on Jesse
Ventura's new show.
We already talked about that earlier,
but I think people look for conspiracy.
There's a lot of conspiracies that are
real,
but there's a lot of shit that people
are just looking for.
Conspiracies.
No
good.
Let's see
on a questions about that.
Jesse Ventura.
You know why?
Because I,
I believe a of weird shit so people
always come to me when it comes to
conspiracy theories,
but like we were talking about earlier,
like Google operation,
northwoods,
Google operation,
midnight,
climax.
Those are.
Those are some conspiracies are fucking
real,
real and proven.
Man,
I can't keep up with these twitters.
Christopher Columbus.
What?
Christopher Columbus did not discover
America.
It's true.
He landed in the Bahamas,
right?
But yet we are.
Celebrate that dude.
Fucking crazy.
What am I coming to Atlanta?
I don't know.
I think the last offer I got from the
comic club wasn't good,
so I might come to Atlanta and do like a
theater or something.
I like comedy clubs.
I liked the idea behind them.
I like supporting these local clubs.
You know that they're keep local
comedians in business and stuff,
but sometimes sometimes I'll give you
the best deal.
Is Brock going to live?
Yes.
I believe Brock Lesnar's going to live.
You're going back to Columbus,
Ohio?
I'm going back to Columbus,
Ohio.
We're trying to go back in March,
but it didn't work out.
I'm going to get a.
When do I get my tattoos done?
I got them a few years ago.
I'm going to do my right arm soon.
Are you really?
Yeah.
I'm going to do a Aaron Dellavedova.
The guy who did disarm.
You going to do that?
Don't do the new one.
Yeah.
What do you think is going to be glad
I'm going to do?
I'm Samurai versus a tiger.
One of those classic Samurai versus a
tiger.
Japanese style tattoos should make the
background bs.
Circuit Board.
Now a circuit board.
Maybe.
I think about adding something weird to
it.
We're still talking about right now.
He hasn't drawn anything.
Everything yet
to Amazon of fucking questions.
Damn you.
Only five minutes deep.
Three hundred 70 players.
Motherfucker.
What am I coming to?
Indianapolis.
Annapolis.
I don't know.
Never been.
Is it good?
No,
don't lie to me.
I've been there.
I went to Pittsburgh once and it smells
like suicide.
Didn't like Indiana is not bad.
It's so boring.
I like to come to places where it's
socks and give people a good time,
but it's going to.
Columbia is make them drive.
Not Too many comments.
Clubs in Atlanta anymore.
They've got a couple.
They've got a lot of good comments to
come out of Atlanta.
I just punch line Atlanta.
Law to good comics come out one.
There's a new comedy clubs I just heard
the other day.
That's really good.
In Atlanta.
No.
Damn.
I lost three people.
I was up to three 78.
Atlanta.
I'm not getting any good questions here.
Bitches.
She questions terrible.
Killer whales.
We were talking about killer whales.
The other problem is a lot of these
people are coming at the end of this and
we've broadcast and for how long now?
Is it still running?
Recording.
Okay,
so what if I look at.
Wow,
that's cool.
Recording for.
We've been talking for an hour and 40
minutes.
That's cool.
It records all of it though.
You can also get a premium channel or 40
minutes.
You know what that means?
I think you can get a premium channel
and ustream ad stuff.
Time to refuel.
What am I in Chicago?
I do not have a Gig in Chicago.
Dino Jitsu.
I don't have anything lined up but I'll
be back there again.
One of my plan to come back to Edmonton,
Alberta.
I was just there a couple of months ago
and the problem is I gotta I gotTa have
new material for you guys and I like to
come no more than once a year so that I
have enough time to write a bunch of new
shit and so I don't.
I don't want you seeing the same act
every time I come.
I want to have a bunch new shit.
I this is the worst feeling in the world
when you're performing for people and
you know,
they're like,
oh,
I've heard this before.
You want them to like some bits.
It's cool.
Like if you want to hear some bits that
you like classics and you want to hear
him live.
I totally understand that,
but I know you want to see mostly new
shit,
so I come to places.
I tried to come no more than once a year
and ideally I like to come every year
and a half.
I like to make sure that you got plenty
of new shit.
Rewrite CD.
Ha.
Brian thinks I need to put my first cd
on DVD,
rewrite it and Redo it.
Rewrite all the jokes and like master
every single jokes.
I think it's better to just leave it
alone and just come up with new shit.
Anything in Philly?
I'll be back in philly again too.
I love that place.
Helium is the shit.
That place is awesome,
but if you go to Joe Rogan.net,
my website,
there's my whole schedule up and it'll
tell you exactly where I'm going to be.
Chattanooga,
Tennessee has a great comedy club.
How dare you just fucking lie to me like
that.
How dare you,
dude?
Trying to Chattanooga,
Tennessee.
I was just in Memphis.
We had a good time in Memphis.
Memphis was fun.
You know what?
I know West Virginia and West Virginia,
Virginia is awesome.
If you ever been at Virginia and West
Virginia,
West Virginia have sex,
but Virginia is kind of cool.
Pittsburgh's smell crud by the funny
bird right there.
We're not all poor.
Hmm,
okay.
Did you know that there's a show called
campus pd and it's cops only on college
campuses.
That's hilarious.
And it's just girls puking get naked.
Just bar fights.
When's the show?
It's on g four.
It's like on every day I think,
and it's called campus.
I think campus pd and it's this cops on
campus
that doesn't seem like it should be
fair.
You shouldn't.
If you're a kid,
first of all,
if you're.
If you're in college,
you're going to want to be on that
stupid show because you're dumb and
you're going to want to be on TV and
it's not fair for them to explain to you
like that your vulnerability,
they have this,
this incredible access.
They can put you on fucking television
like the Jersey shore for sure.
Those guys get mixed.
Some of the people in the show are
blurred out and regular cops and this
show,
but most of the time they're not blurred
because if they're not blurred it means
they signed a release yet.
But did they get.
What did they get?
Did they get off?
Did it get anything like charges off?
Like what is the deal?
That's a good question.
You know,
do they get $500 credit towards bail?
Well,
how bad are there crimes?
Maybe the attempted murder all the way.
I mean,
you've watched cops.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I think a lot of those guys that do it
for money,
they're 50 bucks.
100 bucks,
two bucks on this and a lot of them are
probably so fucking dumb.
You know,
they just sign it.
They just want to be on TV to watch the
Steven Seagal show.
Steven Seagal has got this guy's fucking
arrested.
He's.
They pull them out of the fucking
throwing this guy down in the ground.
You know,
the guy said he had a gun and he got
pulled over in his car and he told them
he had a gun and there you grab on the
yank him out,
you reach into your car and you said you
had a gun.
Oh Man,
I'm just,
I'm just trying to park the car.
You know there is that Steven Seagal,
that Steven's brother,
they got this guy handcuffed.
I mean this guy is going to jail.
He's got a fucking gun in his car
illegally.
They pull him over and all he wants to
do two shakes.
He was wanting to shake.
It's not a Annie Annie.
Fucking brilliant.
It's brilliant.
Nothing more brilliant in the way he
talks to black people though.
He goes into the black boys.
What up?
Because what's going on?
Much love.
Yeah.
He talked to it's black.
It's awesome.
You think cheaters is real or fake?
Cheaters is fake.
Do you think?
All of it or just some of them.
Some of it.
Whatever they need to do.
Yeah.
Some of them.
It's really.
Yeah,
and he got stabbed.
That shit was real fucking stabbed him.
I was watching an episode last night and
this boyfriend tack,
the other boyfriend hasn't been a handle
off.
He's.
I'm like,
wait,
he's just doing this is not going like
you would be just punching his head.
Right?
You wouldn't just be going like,
a lot of it is staged.
They give them some money.
You know?
Jersey shore needs to die.
Rob Fitz.
I hadn't seen it.
He says I disagree.
Rob Fitz.
Oh seven.
Why does it need to die?
I haven't seen there.
They're definitely getting exploited,
but you know what?
Fuck them.
Exploited.
Exploit the shit out of him.
Let me see it.
Let me see the whole thing.
I grew up with people like that.
Guido's don't just exist in,
in New Jersey.
I grew up at Guido's in Boston and
others.
I know a lot of them from east Boston
especially.
I know a lot of Guido's revere.
I used to teach taekwondo at a place
called Nautilus plus and revere revere
Massachusetts.
Did Guido capital of the world.
It was all Iraq's and big hair.
It was like some of my earliest jokes
when I started out doing comedy,
we're all about revere was all about how
growing up in that Shit,
man,
that a good thing is you appreciate
nice,
relaxed,
cool people after you'd been in
environment like that.
You appreciate people that are on a
different frequency instead of always
trying to get pumped up.
You don't try to get swole,
you know,
everybody's trying to wear the right
clothes or wearing cologne pitches like
the smell.
Like I knew so many guys like that.
When I watched Jersey shore,
it's almost a little too painful to me.
Like I knew too many dudes like that.
Rob Fitz.
Oh,
I can't keep going to you buddy.
Bad Bobby.
Hey,
bad bobby.
He says,
I've been smoking weed and watching
Jersey shore all day laughing folks.
You should fall bad.
Bobby.
He's a very fun guy.
Nice guy.
Bobby.
You don't think so because there's two
unknowns and I know one's real and I
know one's not.
Yeah,
the spelling is a little too good,
right?
Might be a fake bad bobby.
Yeah,
that bobby is an internet legend and I
think some people might want to fake
being bad.
Bobby bobby is a real dude.
He owns a strip club.
He was a.
it's a very interesting character.
He was a stockbroker and made a ton of
money and then retired to open up a
strip club in Vancouver.
I just just bangs chicks all day just
because he's just a bad motherfucker.
You just eat steaks,
shoots human,
grows always telling him coffee to just
drink so much coffee.
He's a,
he's a funny dude.
He says really funny shit.
And He um,
he lives in Vancouver.
I can't wait to see them again.
We're going to see them again in June
when we go up there for the UFC
hollaback.
That's the rumor.
UFC in June.
Okay.
The UFC,
Japan.
I want to see that.
I don't know.
It's hard to go over there.
I think so you get some questions here,
man.
The streams coming in too fast.
I can't read these bitches.
That's cool.
[inaudible].
That's the twitter stream.
Did I see the bid on snl about Jersey
shore?
Man,
I haven't watched snl in a long time.
I find it really hard to trust them.
You know,
it's like so many of those sketches are
just not funny.
It's too hard to trust,
you know,
to like commit to sitting there and it's
one of those things.
I'll give you a few.
I'll watch the clips when there's things
in,
on the Internet that really funny.
Like Dick in a box.
Remember that.
That was an snl gag,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
I watched them when they get to the
Internet,
but I can't.
I'm,
I need somebody else to edit it,
find the funny ones and make a big deal
out of it.
I can't commit to watching that show.
I seen avatar yet.
No,
I have not.
We're going to.
Brian and I are going to go see it
probably the day after Christmas.
We're going to get fucking trimmed up
and go to this.
I guess one way that we could go to the
D.
Yeah.
I think we're already going to have
heart attacks and that's the way to do
it.
I'm not crazy.
Not what turns per.
No.
I took a little and I was,
well,
let's just go with pot cookies.
Popcorn.
That's fine.
I got some pot cookies and it just like
shrooms.
Yeah.
It might as well be drums.
I can talk about ancient alien theories.
He says in all capsj,
g one slash 29.
Please talk about ancient alien
theories.
The big theory of the ancient alien
theories is that human beings were
manufactured and that they use genetic
manipulation to take monkeys and add
alien DNA to the monkeys to make people.
When you think about that,
Brian,
I think Asians are aliens.
They could be right.
And maybe that's why they saw.
Fuck is calling me while I'm on my
podcast.
Goddammit.
Um,
let's
excuse me.
I'm in the middle of a podcast.
Oh,
how much longer should I be?
Okay.
You want me to end soon?
Hi,
I'm often daddy's.
Daddy's on the Internet.
Okay.
Ten minutes.
Gentlemen,
that's,
that's the reality.
See you see me fucking standup comedian
slash cage fighter.
No Pussy,
whipped husband and daddy.
Daddy has to stop smoking weed and doing
his little webcam show because everybody
wants to eat.
And they want to open up Christmas
presents.
Merry Christmas.
You'd already pitches.
What was I talking about before that
happened?
Oh,
we're talking about ancient aliens.
Yeah.
You were saying what is,
what's your theories are?
Asians were like,
aliens landed and had Asians and then
like did not like the Asians nowadays
aren't aliens,
but there are a breed of aliens.
Like maybe they're more alien than we
are.
Maybe there was like different
formulations.
Maybe that's what all the different
breeds of human beings are,
you know,
different,
like Italians were just much.
And they're pure.
They're more pure to the actual human
race,
you know,
they're,
well definitely Asians are more pure.
I mean there's,
there's billions of them and they look
very similar.
That's incredible.
They managed to do that.
Yeah.
I mean I guess they'd probably look at
Europeans and a similar way,
but the difference is with the blonde
hair,
red hair and brown hair,
Europeans come in all different colors
and sizes,
but even like you go Korean to Japanese,
to Chinese,
it's all black hair.
It's all real similar skin tones.
I mean,
God damn,
there's some similarities.
I would love to be Asian,
I think.
Really?
Yeah.
Do you have an excuse for having such a
little Dick?
Oh No.
I mean seriously.
You don't have to shave.
Most of them don't have to shave.
I hate shaving,
dude.
I fucking hate it.
Well,
you save everything.
You make it an adventure.
I'll keep my ball,
my lower ball hair or shave off because
there's some great ones in there I'm
trying to avoid.
But my upper pillars,
I leave those pitches alone.
I trim them a little bit
when I was,
when I lived alone,
I would take it and put it on a trash
bag and roll around like a pig just so
to get it all over my back and then you
can really get the,
the scraper scraper.
So then you'd have to get like a towel
on the towel and you just rub hard.
Really work.
Yeah.
Wow.
Brian,
innovative hair loss methods by Brian
and Michael had a nice thick mountain
man.
Beard for a while back when I was,
uh,
doing that.
Uh,
Evan Tanner.
Attribute beard.
I have a good one going,
but I haven't shaved for something.
I had to do.
Rejoined the human rejoin society.
Well,
back when I came back from Colorado too.
I was really thinking about growing one
in Colorado,
but that might push me over the edge
when I was living in Colorado on the top
of a mountain.
If I had a beard up there too,
I probably would have got way close to
an animal,
you know,
if I let my cell phone.
It's crazy.
Harry,
was there any point of living there like
that?
You were just outside and you're just
like,
Holy Shit,
this is scary.
You know,
what am I doing here?
Definitely.
It was definitely scary,
but that was part of the appeal of it to
me is that it was so off the grid.
It was show outside of the way a normal
person every day gets to experience
life.
I was living in the fucking woods,
not just kind of in the woods.
I was living on 150 acres on the top of
a mountain in Boulder,
Colorado outside of boulder.
I mean,
it was like nine miles above boulder.
It was pretty trippy,
8,500
feet above sea level and all sorts of
wildlife.
Deer every day.
Dear.
I was on a dirt road for eight miles
dear everyday.
I would see deer every day.
I would see foxes occasionally.
I'd see porcupines people,
Peoplesoft bear.
I never saw bear something outline in my
backyard.
I mean,
you saw a lot of shit,
eagles all the time.
I mean,
it was really intense.
It was so real,
you know,
it was just,
it was so like,
you know,
you're driving,
you're seeing wild animals.
Like we'll wild animals.
Big fucking 10 point bucks walking down
the street,
you know,
and it's very,
very interesting.
It's just the fact that you can live
somewhere like that.
It's such A.
I think people get stuck in patterns and
I think it's real easy to get stuck in
the same way of thinking,
the same way of looking at the world and
nothing changes that like moving to a
new place for awhile and moving to a
place that's as stunning as the
mountains of Colorado.
I would love to go back,
but it's just not practical to have a
wife and kids and you know,
and have little vulnerable babies and
being around fucking wild monsters.
I mean my dog had eaten by a mountain
lion when we were up there.
That's for real.
Like we saw a mountain lion.
I let the little dog out by himself.
Dog Disappears.
I mean that's all got eaten by a fucking
mountain lion,
you know,
which is very likely and those animals
died of predation up there all the time.
It's very common.
They even pray on animals.
They get used to them.
They get used to recognizing and
associating the barks,
barks of these animals with like pray
and so they go towards where they hear
barks.
So it's actually kind of dangerous when
you have a fucking house with dogs
barking because sometimes these mountain
lions,
like if they're hungry it,
especially if they're old and they can't
catch dear anymore,
they know these dogs are like in a cage
over their fence.
Like it ain't shit.
Jack Dogs,
they do it all the time.
They're scary as fuck.
Do you think people that sleep with guns
underneath their pills,
if that's just fake.
Somebody said it once to impress a girl.
No,
I know I've got.
It does.
It really is just seeing them as like,
that's dumb.
Well,
if you want it,
if you want it to have it right there.
If you live in a place where you think
you're going to need it,
right?
I mean,
look,
it doesn't seem like it's a good idea,
but what if someone breaks in your house
and you need the gun and you just go
like that and you got the gun and then
that keeps you alive.
There's that way of looking at it.
You know?
There's the way of looking at it like,
hey man,
if you think that way,
man,
fucking nothing can happen to you,
man.
As long as you think positive,
you can sing that way.
It be one of those dudes that goes
through life convinced that nothing ever
bad is gonna happen to you.
You know?
I mean that that is possible.
You might sneak through,
but shit might get ugly.
Shit gets ugly.
You want one of these bitches,
this shit's important.
Guns,
ladies and gentlemen.
I believe in the second amendment.
I believe.
Go shooting Santana.
Haven't been shooting it.
Let's go.
Uh,
let's go on Monday.
Cool.
I think I'm definitely.
Gun Control's important.
You gotta definitely screen people.
You got to definitely make sure that
people don't,
you know,
the,
the people can't get access to guns that
are fucking crazy and that,
you know,
and that's the problem with a lot of gun
shows is there's a lot of people that
sell guns at gun shows that don't give a
fuck if you're licensed or not.
They're just trying to make some money.
And there's been expos there on that
where they've shown that people in gun
shows will sell guns to people that
don't know.
Not really supposed to have guns,
but
the guns are out there.
They're fucking out there,
there's millions of them.
You're not going.
You usually have one,
you know,
if there's millions of guns out there,
better to have it and did not need it
than to need it and not have it.
That's,
you know,
I'm,
I'm an optimist.
I'm not a pessimist.
I'm not,
you know,
I,
I believe that most human beings are
good,
but I've come across way too many fucked
up people to have complete and total
blind trust in the human race.
I just don't.
I've,
I've seen way too many fucked up violent
things happen.
I've seen way too many crazy people I've
come in contact with and had to deal
with way too many fucking crazy people.
There's a lot of people out there that
you can't reason with.
are just broken and nuts and that's
real.
Okay.
Oh,
is that sanas bells since bells was
living in Los Angeles?
Bells?
No.
I mean,
is that Santa is you're saying we have
to end this.
Wouldn't have to end this real soon.
Do you do to do what?
UFC superfight what?
I'd like to see brock lesnar versus
door.
That's what I would like to say.
That's what everybody would should want
to say.
Oh,
that's a diaper diaper.
This is my reality.
Ladies and gentleman,
good diapers in my office,
my boss' office with my make me hard
poster.
I got to fucking Oakley split.
Nope.
I don't know.
We'll talk later.
Oh,
that's those eyeglasses that are empty
MP.
Three players.
That's the kind that dog.
The bounty hunter.
Whereas Hollaback.
It's hilarious.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
this has been very interesting.
We were up to 379 motherfuckers.
I want to thank you for tuning in.
This is,
um,
we're going to do this much more often
now that I have this set up.
And I finally installed this Webcam that
I bought like five.
Yeah.
You got to get your internet faded.
You get new HD.
I'm going to get my internet updated it
hd cameras now.
Fifty nine bucks on Amazon.
Look for the.
Yeah.
Well no you don't.
That's actually an old camera now.
Does that sound good now?
But it looks okay.
Yeah,
that's okay.
But see,
it's an hd.
You can,
you can be.
Bragg has nate steering it.
But isn't that like more bandwidth for
Beulah download.
You have a net when you have 20
megabytes,
you know,
but crazy doesn't affect them.
It affects them downloading it.
It only affects up upload once.
Once I get the Internet,
do it,
I'll make it.
I'll make it hd so you can see the ugly,
ugly.
All right.
What else we got here?
One of the next time I'm going to be
used streaming Johnny Bananas.
That's a very good question.
Um,
I think we're good.
What I'm going to try to do is,
uh,
my,
my ultimate goal in 2010 is I'm trying
to write a book right now and I've been
spending a lot of time writing that,
writing standup comedy and not so much
time updating my website,
but I do go on twitter because twitter
is fun for me and it's like a little
exercise in writing to make things short
and make them 140 characters.
I think that's fun.
So it is,
it teaches you to like,
you know,
edit your shit with comedy.
That's very important.
Economy of words.
It's what it's called.
And in stand up comedy,
it's very important that the less words
you could use to make a point,
the funnier it's going to be when it
hits people,
the more you,
the more verbose it is,
the more it's not funny when it gets
there.
So,
uh,
I think twitter's real good for that.
But my point is in 2010,
what I'm.
My main goal is more on the Internet.
More shit like this,
more ustream shit.
More twitter and definitely more blogs.
But I'm going to start doing more video
shit and I'm carrying A.
I got a cool flip thing from the UFC for
Christmas,
which is perfect.
I'm going to bring that bitch with me
everywhere.
I'm going to start putting shit online
on youtube on a really regular basis.
And I know there's a little ustream,
a streaming thing for the iphone.
We're going to try that shit out.
But it's probably gay.
Yeah.
Everyone Wifi,
it's not bad.
You actually see the chat on the screen
too.
Oh really?
Yeah.
If you're on Wifi,
it's good.
It's good.
Yeah.
I mean I've tried on three g Wifi.
That means I'm on a fucking computer.
Why?
Fuck around unless you were at Denny's.
Denny's.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Welcome to 2009 people.
Shit is getting crazy.
Well,
listen,
I gotta go.
I gotta go eat dinner with my family.
I don't want to leave people hungry.
We've got exchange presidents and all
that good shit.
I love you motherfuckers.
Thank you very much for tuning in.
And uh,
we are going to do this again.
Don't know when,
but within a week,
right?
Yeah.
We'll come in and just do it once a
week.
Once a week.
Two hours once
a week.
I didn't have to go.
All right.
I love you guys.
Thank you very much.
Bye.
Two hours once a week.
I'm movie is two hours.
You could do a movie once a week.
Yeah.
You.
So bios thinking is how gay is this all
going to look?
Looking back at it in 50 years.
Do we save this recording?
I know.
I think it stays it to your page so
people can go to your page,
hit stop and see what it says.
I think stopped it.
Oh,
see,
this is stopped.
Wait,
no,
you said it started.
Stopped broadcast.
Hit Stop Record.
So yeah.